hello everybody happy Friday it's May
5th happy Friday AKA Cinco de Mayo
we were wondering oh well today's
episode is sponsored by native sunscreen
thank you so much you know we are
wondering
if we should do something for Cinco de
Mayo like we did on uh St Patrick's Day
but I says
I'm definitely gonna be canceled I don't
know what we're planning or what we're
gonna do but I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
in trouble
see don't even somehow I feel like even
that's racist why I just feel it Dan
just playing I can't touch this one
vaguely play turn it up Zach let me hear
it
oh oh
[Music]
no comment
[Applause]
[Music]
no comment for me
I don't recall playing bagpipes on St
Patrick's Day well that'd be weird
because that's Scottish
nice similar close right they probably
have bagpipes yeah come on
well everybody thanks for being here Ela
came in Stunting Like Ruby Ross
from Fifth Element and she's so tall she
was straight up giving me big ladies
stomping you guys look at this
wait hold on hold on she looks perfect
you guys remember Ruby Ross oh wait
that's a real person Ruby Rose no no no
Ruby Ross Ruby Rod is the characters I
believe oh Ruby Rose I found at somebody
else yeah that's a real person Orange is
the New Black okay Ruby Ruby Rose
no no that's what it says here
oh it does it oh it's Ruby Rod no it is
Ruby rod
this is you right now this is you this
is you that's literally you oh my god
with the flowers I do love that one so
wait stand up let's see it
okay she's got three inch high heels on
yeah
let's go
that's awesome is that a vintage dress
what's the story with it
honestly this one actually don't know
but uh we went to this place that has a
bunch of vintage designer stuff but it's
also mixed in with just random things
and I rented it for today and it's gonna
be part of my new Vlog okay
[Applause]
yeah nice so I've been recording all
week with Lina Lina behind the camera
what what did you guys do it's just a
day
um yeah kind of we went to life yeah we
went to look for this what I'm gonna
wear today and then we did a day in the
office and yeah oh my God a real Vlog oh
my gosh
yep well that's exciting how do these
gloves stay on I always wondered like do
these come right off yeah
so they don't they don't like droop at
all on your arm a little bit I do keep
fixing you know what I mean yeah I
thought maybe there's some like women
witchcraft you know
um I could have done that but it was all
very last minute so what's the question
yeah there's a sticky tape I could do
here
who's got the time
I just had a really obscene joke but I'm
not gonna say it nice I'm proud of you
not on Cinco de Mayo
[Music]
being good today for our neighbors I
noticed that though lately you're like
you actually developed the option in
your brain to stop it from like you're
like well there's been a lot of button
action that's it I mean are they finally
a couple of times over the week if you
had our earliest button uh yet uh about
I believe it was about 90 seconds into
the show wait what when
it was like on Monday or something I
don't I don't remember what it was but
you know
yeah but um
it's causing that perception though and
I believe uh I believe that's nice
that's good no I definitely saw you say
a couple of times like I have a joke but
I'm not gonna say it and you didn't yeah
but the times that I do say it you just
see the
that's good you know it's a it's a war
on two fronts I think you're growing up
ELO what the [__] is this dude
what is this this is you being all tall
and me being a tiny little [__] Jew
Israeli clowns of uh Jordan Peterson
okay he's this crazy Israeli clown
comedian what is this Paparazzi shot I'm
telling you based on this photo we are
getting divorced
that's what Christian fit you can be
like yo tell me this couple to get
divorced
yeah you were so proud of that one did
you see that did we wash that together
we have not
well anyway uh today we've got a fun
show planned we have a
an accent coach uh you guys decided to
intervene
apparently y'all got a problem with my
accents the one accent y'all really
gonna bring a accent coaching here and
teach me
a good old God blessed American
yeah I got a new accent I kind of feel
like the next step maybe after today
would be to actually send you through
America
to learn
method acting yeah that's right you know
get to know the people and really learn
that just get in the method
do you want me to get in the method so
you mean like I got a shotgun over my
shoulder here I've seen a man on the far
side of my Lake I'm shooting the kill
now you'll actually need to be on that
Lake and really understand yeah yeah we
saw a video yesterday of uh this dude
was just fishing in a pond and a dude on
the other side of the pond just came out
and started shooting
that's America so that's it that's the
method acting
yeah so we've got the coach coming in
we've got uh all kinds of fun things
uh
yeah
um chocolate mocha you know the megala
happened this week yeah I kind of went
over that on them yeah I'm sorry oh the
member stream okay yeah but we could do
it here I mean honestly I don't have
much to say I was kind of disappointed
overall really because everybody was
hyping me up for this one
um maybe not everybody but some people
were saying oh this one's gonna be cool
because there's so much to pull from
there's like Carl lager for years of
History
and it's gonna be a fun one to play with
and I was like when people started
showing up I was like this looks like an
just like a family wedding where you're
kind of regular and just like show up
with a boring dress you know elf fashion
morons idiots oh it looked way better
um
I did love Rihanna
there was some really good fits there
were a few good ones yeah yeah I don't
mean to um take it away from the cool
people there were some good ones
but I just I guess I just don't feel
like I have much to say oh you know who
it was really good was um Jenny she
looked [__] stunning
oh what's that she's from blackpink
right
can you show it Jenny from blackpink she
is stunning in her little dress right
that was such a cute outfit I actually
think that was a cute outfit I think
you're joking yeah
I specifically brought it up I said
Jenny is stunning and tell everybody I
said that
Jenny from blackpink
the little white strapless here here's
what she looked like absolutely stunting
stunning legendary look who has more
style and grace than Jenny from
blackpink
nobody
uh listen
she is cool yep hey uh hey uh Gabe
what's going on
happy Cinco de Mayo
so how are you celebrating Cinco de Mayo
Gabe
see lots of alcohol behind you some
tequila shots and [__] [__]
oh [__] [__] baby hey can you tell me
what is Cinco de Mayo what do we
celebrate on this day
I think it's Mexican Independence Day a
celebration for oh my God okay
I think I'm getting notes uh that that
is not correct
nope sorry guys I'm seeing victory over
the French army uh some sort of thing
like that that is correct and but that
wasn't Independence what were they
fighting for
well it's just one battle in a war uh
against the French Empire they got a
whole day for one battle it was a
significance turning point in the war
W okay who am I to say so so I actually
put a whole little write up for you
about what Cinco de Mayo is in the dock
knowing that you'd probably know that I
already know all this Dan I didn't need
you to do that Cinco de Mayo is a yearly
celebration held on May 5th
of Mexico's victory over the second
French Empire are you taking notes Gabe
yeah to celebrate goddamn French they
they [__] up every war they fought in
mm-hmm
except when they helped us in the
Revolutionary War they did find me that
was all us yeah whatever more popular in
the United States than Mexico they say
Cinco de Mayo has been become associated
with the celebration of Mexican American
culture the celebrations began in
California where they have been observed
annually oh so this is um this is kind
of a local celebration here in SoCal the
Cinco de Mayo okay
what a fantastic phenomenon
and Gabe you look like uh you're just
Bells right now [__]
shout to Tequila how deep in are you
Gabe how many shots deep are you
doing you're feeling good
I just said
is this a new song yeah he brings some
new beats usually on Friday and
surprising us
four photos
that's also Cinco de Mayo beaches
what does Cinco de Mayo mean Gabe do you
know what that means in if you were to
translate it to English
it's 5th of May this guy he knows it all
genius
which is today
so you guys having a party over there
what's popping uh is it just you
I have some people who are having more
drinks take some tequila shots and go
wow [__] [__] and Cinco de Mayo
[Applause]
I don't know can we do a poll is this
music racist or what
uh sure let's do it yeah let's do a poll
I mean you know I just try to be very
polite very thoughtful you know
let the people decide yeah can we can
Ethan listen to mariachi music was that
mariachi music yeah
okay
you want to have some
all right well listen Gabe I'm glad this
music races
20 said yes no I'm not alone
20 is too much right 21 yeah I mean
there you go yeah you want this to be
like a 95.5 kind of that's what I'm
sorry yeah that's what I'm saying if
it's racist don't do it I want to get in
trouble
all right um
game listen you have fun out there you
have a blessed a beautiful Cinco de Mayo
[__] the French army l losers idiots why
are we okay with that though okay [__]
the French yeah [__] them though well
we're celebrating the defeat of the
French army and to be fair it's not
racist because everybody hates the
French
do we okay
yeah yeah
that's a given oh [__] we'll see what
you have to say on Bastille Day oh best
deal day that's true [__] the English
I'm Bastille Day well you know
all right Gabe you wow you look you look
kind of laid out there bud
I'm just relaxing yeah yeah that's nice
all right you have a great day you you
get some rays drink some Coronas do
whatever it is you got to do okay we
drink beer
[__] yeah
okay
[__] [__]
take take some boogers and finger my
butthole with them
I was just gonna say that game hasn't
been so much into that kind of stuff but
he just said it so oh no we're bringing
it yeah take a bottle of tequila and
shove it up my ass and then put me to a
handstanding
puke it out of my mouth [__]
out of my eyes and shut it in my ears
soak some tortilla and tequila and shove
it up my [__] [__] turn me into a
taco baby
get out of my butt and put it in my eye
[__]
hey Gabe hey Gabe shave off my turds
like El Pastor baby
no yes
that was too far
all right Gabe have a great day I can
tell you're gonna have a good one okay
oh yeah be good [__] baby
oh
[Music]
my God
oh you can't sleep that's not fair
I think the serious game is I've almost
made me laugh all right Gabe you're good
thank you bro love you thank you so much
have a good weekend
[Applause]
baby [__] uh that's why claw game
everything sure is so no moss on the
music is that the uh no I'm kidding I
don't okay I just you know I'm just
being sensitive I'm just you know no no
I'm just trying to get the festivities
just trying to be uh
just trying to be sensitive to our you
know
to our neighbors
is that racist
oh my God that's what they do
that's what they do I think it's only
racist because that was that was so bad
when exactly so hard do you get worried
you're [__] better dude
the canary in the coal mines
all right now play the music and let me
test grab that no
yeah yeah but this is soft this is
installed there's more mariachi oh God
this is Spanish no it's not salsa are
you talking about the dancing
specifically this is mariachi music
that's Spanish right that's something
else completely
[Music]
Tango right
right I don't know
you got a better one Dan you make fun of
my Mariachi scream
I do but I don't know if it's a problem
do it bro drop it no the time isn't
right come on I gotta feel it out I
Gotta Throw It Out Daniel what's the
Mariachi scream all right
and I'll tell you what else Dan you
should be scared as [__] because I'm
weighing in at 2 15.
you should be scared because I'm gonna
have to put mayonnaise on my head when
you break 200 I'm well aware and I
encourage it I welcome it even should
mail up that Dome there it is two years
ago long time fans will know I've been
trying to get below 200 pounds for what
two or three years I was just gonna say
that people even know about the the lore
it's been a long time 200.
but in truth um Dan who hates mayonnaise
as promised to slather his head and man
in honor of me
and then is it possible to
because it's kind of flat just as a
concept maybe what we can do is do like
egg salad and then we can make
sandwiches off your head or something
why are you why are you changing the
deal I'm just trying to make it more
we've had a contract for years to make
it more entertaining there's so
entertaining it's it's built up for
years Mayo up that Dome you're gonna try
and uh okay fine fine here salad up that
dog okay okay wait all right so we'll
we'll have a bowl of eggs and you know
pickles there's no pool hold on damn
hear me out
and then while your head is lathered up
in mayo we'll take them we'll scoop the
mail off his head and then put it in the
bowl make egg salad and then you have to
eat the egg salad I'm gonna peel because
I'll take a bite of that sandwich I'll
do it with you Dan Dan you don't want me
to lose weight you want me fat what
you're the one that's going back on our
deal
like an ice cream place and then we each
get to pick what we want to put on his
head as he goes down the line yeah
that'd be nice so wait a b say what like
an ice cream place where we all pick out
a different topping to put on his head
as he goes down the line but like all
mayonnaise based it could be mayonnaise
and then like ice cream toppings like
sprinkles and stuff I think it should
all be mayonnaise based because last
time we put whipped cream on his head he
wasn't really bothered by that Dan
so I'm talking tuna salad
egg salad uh potato salad
right any other mayonnaise chicken salad
chicken salad oh yeah no chicken salad
Joey salad
pasta salad
macaroni salad
I think you're just trying to force my
hands so that you don't have to commit
that's a good point well do you know
what I wanted to read it and it's like
oh well Dan won't even do it so I guess
I don't have to lose the weight no no no
no
listen I'm making egg salad on your
[__] head bro or you're fired
[Laughter]
I wonder
yo dude you wouldn't let me put an egg
Style on his head what the [__] I mean
Steven Crowder he whips out his deck so
I mean this this is yeah yeah what are
you gonna do if I hit 190 I'm gonna tea
bag you by the way
okay that's a good idea
oh my God it doesn't work Dan goes
either Dan goes that doesn't work either
that doesn't work either have you gave
us your best one yet this was my first
attempt go ahead that doesn't work
either can I hear it
that doesn't work either oh that was
pretty good it doesn't work either
Zach has my favorite one go ahead no
that doesn't work either you hit it like
rock and roll kind of like yeah it's the
cigarette
I like that
um
so where were we we were talking about
uh we have things to talk about did you
um did you know about Crowder putting
his balls on people at work did you read
about that no gila's been kind of
catching up on the Crowder stuff but a
new article came out in the New York
Post which is a conservative publication
so that is interesting they interviewed
10 ex-employs okay six of them recall
seeing him take exposing himself to
people
including putting his dick and balls on
employees while they slept no way
six employees all testified for that
including one in what context does a
person do that in the context of a
really fun inviting work environment
epic pranks
LLC or whatever you are [__] nope
right now
and then one of the guys who was gay who
he called not what do you call him not
not gay Jared not gay Jared lovely that
he targeted him with one of these pranks
when he was sleeping and put his dick
and balls on him are you serious I am
dead I'm serious as a as a chest
uh concave surgery
I mean do you go to jail like what I
feel that they could press charges if
they press charges that's something they
wanted to for some reason the 10
employees were like we don't want
anything bad to happen to Stephen we
just want people to know what they're
getting themselves into I was like the
[__]
here's Dan getting uh Stephen Amor says
getting uh frosting on his dog why does
this look so real this is real the
frosting but look how happy he doesn't
care you gotta up there
you know
he's gonna care when it's mayonnaise
yeah exactly the Mayo was already like
the crazy thing to do and you're trying
to up the Annie okay well it doesn't
matter to you if I scoop up your head
and make egg salad with it
whatever you do with the Mayo afterwards
is fine yeah anything
you're you're paying for it you can do
whatever you want with that mail your
dollar I'm about to do some gamer bath
water with that Mayo boy oh what um
[Applause]
yes sir
Zach did do a mailbox death he sure did
fucker's a craft
oh yeah so anyway
um
we have a drop we are actually gonna do
a little fashion show for everybody
today you know we always have fun when
we do that the new collection my fun way
came out and let's get the let's get the
music going oh Jesus
you know what AB looks
stunning
you want to go first JB
this is all on the website now at
teddyfresh.com
oh
here it is
go ahead ELO now okay Enter stage a b
the beauty the bomb there he is and the
marble black and white hit him with it
that's a squat
um crew neck we got the neon logo rubber
yeah
oh boy I saw those not part of the
collection up down up I saw those
you look great though baby
stunning yeah we felt like with this
collection we wanted to do neon colors
for the logo so we did the new version
of the rubber patch
and you can see it on the hat too hat
okay
all right okay settle down okay all
right yeah okay okay thank you baby
looking fantastic that's the marble uh
one of course Zach we had to put the
camp shirt on him because he's the man
yeah he's cool he's hip he rocks Camp
Shark Tank and that V he knows how to do
that V down I saw you I could see your
nipple bro from the side having a nip
slipped there my friend
so for this one we took all oh okay not
part of the collection guys let's focus
for this one we took all the different
artworks that she created for us and um
just did like a print Mash
Clash
of a
artwork shadowing the chi of the Earth
Wind and Fire
yeah
sick isn't it amazing when you realize
she created it all with the tie-dye oh
well we posted it actually might be nice
to show some context of how cool her art
is thank you Zach happy Cinco de Mayo
here here's how she makes it just as a
reference okay because she has these
huge pools and then she Paints in them
super cool
yeah yeah uh okay Olivia okay
this is a multi-media sweater right ELO
yes we we mix different textures of
Yarns different quality Yarns so that
you have a little bit of fuzziness on
the sweater itself but then the bear is
extra fuzzy and then the eyes are kind
of like a mix of embroidery and stuff
it's very cute it's all happening and
it's all happening it's recycled content
all Olivia 100 recycled yarn refresh.com
100 recycled yeah oh my God
happy Cinco de Mayo girl
[Laughter]
um
Lena oh my goodness here she is
uh with the overalls you know what those
are sold out I'm so it's so surprising
to me so when we started working on this
it was in a different fabric the first
fabric we didn't love so we were kind of
Unsure how this overall would turn out
so we did small quantities yeah and then
during the development time we figured
it out we got it on the cool nice Fabric
and it turned out so cool and now
there's only a very limited amount of
them I wonder if we could oh it's sold
out already I don't know but you know it
looks so good on your leaning stunting
mm-hmm okay show her shoes yeah they're
just I mean yeah Converse a happy Cinco
de Mayo
happy singing Back cam oh my God oh my
God there's a snake on you watch out oh
wow
oh who knows
that's Kim everybody loves cam yes yes
they do yeah
in his own right I don't think it's
right to give that Foley to AV because I
do see lots of thirsting for Cameron
lately oh yeah I see that too and this
shirt is um light and Breezy and soft it
is oversized and it is recycled as well
the only thing cooler is if you put a
pack of cigarettes in your sleeve nope
that would not be cool bring them out we
gotta get we got it would not be cool we
had cigarettes look how cool he is
gross gross
Undateable yuck oh
do you know how to roll it
yeah you know you're supposed to roll it
in your sleep that's like all that's
like a greaser kind of old school thing
yeah yeah all right all right I tried I
tried yeah
thank you Cam stunning okay here's Dan
with this beautiful okay marbled
colorful crew neck ELO honestly the
colors are so colorful in person I feel
like the camera can't even capture it
properly
um it's that's the second colorway she
created we kind of gave her like colors
in mind that we wanted to see and then
she went and created this beautiful
masterpiece
um yeah Dan like Leonardo da Vinci's
sketch of a man he is man he is
human he is everything and more put both
hands out since you're doing a pose put
both hands out
do like this no I want okay now now put
your left hand down
I just want to see what it looks like
from that angle
thank you Dan looking fantastic I guess
okay
oh Ian up
Ethan is on his way surely taking his
time
you know you're not on camera yet okay
here we go
he was walking like that
all right this is the mushroom artwork I
feel like this marble colorway is so
Ethan by the way and I love it in a
perfect way Ethan's perf Ethan's
favorite color is purple
and so to me this black brown purple and
gray marble is like I see Ethan in that
and I love it
um yeah it's the same same content
recycled Breezy light soft
and that's it it's tired
and show the shoes show the shoes that
are falling apart
I have people at home asking me what is
Ethan gonna do his shoes are falling
apart do you want to buy him new shoes
and I'm like I don't know he's a grown
person
oh then Ian I think oh okay you can do
it ELO we should show off your outfit
I feel like puking
I don't know what happened I ate I could
take a couple bites to eat this burrito
oh my God you look amazing oh my God
look at her we needed that whole body we
needed it
uh-oh camera froze you know why because
yellow was so hot yeah those protons
were coming in way too uh
you burned the sensor up you let's chill
okay girl damn did you get a good shot
okay she's out wow
oh my God I feel like I'm gonna puke oh
no that burrito did not did not we ate
it in like two seconds
something's wrong
give my pregnancy
while you're recovering
sure yeah
well okay so today I was supposed to be
able to do the blood test and find out
what I thought I was gonna find out now
actually
but then they called me and they said
that it's too soon today it's only seven
days
foreign
[Music]
we gotta bring back the light
oh I'm back already so the what's the
theory there Dan Dan said hit the button
because I replugged in our connection
and it would have glitched out and
Frozen on the screen basically we used
it as an actual technical difficulties
card okay
now all these audio issues we're
assuming hey B is uh derived from the
button but
is that right Dan uh it's I actually
have identified what's going on and it
has more to do with the switching
computer
um I have to get a new card for it which
is going to take a while to get so we're
just making do in the meantime okay all
right Dan he always making it work
um I'm gonna take this off to type
um so so is everything works looks like
it is better now yeah go ahead let me
talk again about oh I don't know where
it was left off uh you just said that
you're supposed to get tested today oh
yeah so they basically have to wait
until Monday now which really sucks I
haven't been sleeping all week and I
think this is why
okay Dennis saying he still thinks
something's not right
[Music]
you know um
it's not as bad now but
you know um we can definitely hear you
and I'm going through
but I'll sleep for like two hours max
wake up
like I cannot sleep for more than two
hours at a time and I have to force
myself to go to sleep and I just feel
like [__] all day every day so I don't
know if you've talked about it but
because the because Bruce wakes up so
much I end up taking him with me to bed
and then when Ethan goes to sleep late
he would totally
um first we'll totally wake up and so we
ended up started we started sleeping in
different rooms now
and I sleep with Bruce and then Teddy
sometimes comes too but when it comes to
my room also it's
um
the this whole week I don't know I've
been waking up and then I can't go back
to sleep and I'll have like the same
thoughts drive me crazy when I'm like
I'm trying to tell myself like just go
to sleep what are you thinking about
it can be work it can be whatever I'm
doing the next day it's just like I
can't stop thinking the same stuff I
hate that I hate it and I can't go to
sleep
um and then I don't know I started to
think that maybe it's just because I'm
nervous to find out the results there's
a lot happening probably the baby thing
also you're like you have so much
hormones and the hormones I still take
hormones twice a day and I think that's
driving me crazy everybody's screaming
divorce in chat coconuts in the forest
oh yeah they're gonna love it we sleep
in separate rooms well go wild it's been
like go wild with that where we don't
sleep in separate rooms it's literally
just literally a couple of weeks because
of the kids were not letting us sleep
yeah oh no no coconuts are divorced
we happen to have a spare guest room I
mean we had a friend who used to sleep
on the floor or some [__] because you
know they had two girls
uh and he slept on the floor of her room
so if you have kids yeah you know you
got to do whatever it takes Burns no
you've got to do whatever it will take
to get those kids to sleep
um so well it depends because if I sleep
in the bed it sounds it seems like a
good idea the problem is I come to bed
later so when when Bruce is in there
it doesn't matter how quiet I am I swear
to God now when I come in he wakes up
and he's like and he thinks it's like
play time he's ready to play with me
yeah
it's cute it's super cute but he'll like
stand up and start playing and stuff he
looks at me and then he's got this big
ass smile and he's like oh Daddy's here
let's play and uh and then you see
strata because usually the dogs come
with Ethan
then he sees the dogs he starts wanting
to climb to their side and it becomes a
whole mess it's cute and it's fun for
like 20 minutes but he won't go to sleep
for like an hour or two and then I give
him like a pill bottle and he is his
favorite toy he'll take the pill bottle
and he starts shaking it he thinks it's
so awesome
so I have to wait until Monday
and I am going crazy I find it annoying
that they told you you'll find out on
Friday I know and then they said wait
till Monday why'd they tell you and the
doctors I messaged the doctor and I was
like Hey the nurses said I it's too soon
should I do you think I can do it Friday
and she said yes then we told the nurses
and they said again no don't do it
Friday it's too soon but the doctor said
yes yeah so what the hell why are you
listening to the nurses because I
actually looked online and it says the
same thing it says that seven days is
too soon
and so also you were feeling like yeah
last night yeah I was starting yeah yeah
I was starting to have a back pain last
night like the way I would get before I
got my period And so I'm like oh no did
it not work out am I about to get my
period
um I don't know so
I feel like there's so much on the line
because if this doesn't happen would you
want to go for a boy yeah that's funny I
don't think if it doesn't work then it's
a third boy but would you do you feel
the need for to go for it then I mean at
this point I feel like we might as well
you think so yeah I mean we have to
stunt on all these alpha males we have
to keep Pro creating because like you
know I guarantee you we're gonna we come
all this way yeah I know and now we have
all these bomb ass triple quadruple A4
eggs which if you guys don't know is
like the Kobe beef of uh
embryos yeah
we got those AAS
and then once that third boy is born
though then we're gonna be like it's CR
in like 5 10 or whatever to 18 years or
20 years we'll be like yeah it's crazy
to think that we almost didn't have you
yeah yeah yeah so I think we're gonna
have a third no matter what okay that's
actually making me less stressed but
because for some reason I thought we
would decide
if it's not a girl we're done
I think it's God's plan
if it's not a girl then it's a boy well
the funny thing is that it's it's
totally not it's very sciency we get to
choose God's plan God's plan we get to
choose what we want to do what I mean is
if it doesn't work out with the girl uh
you know I mean like I thought maybe you
would think well then we don't need why
is the viewers going down there's
something up with the stream it's like
down down down down down I don't is that
35 and it keeps going down down it's not
a girl do you see that
why do you even have that Jack
that wasn't me I think that was Ethan uh
the sound that was me oh oh yeah it
keeps going down I don't know if it
could pause maybe something to do with
the refresh a lot of people refreshed
whenever we had audio issues
um
I remember really seen it like that
they're bored I don't know I've never
seen that
um
so I was gonna say is while I under well
I will all be bummed that the girl
didn't work out I'm saying that
sometimes life uh has other plans and so
with the third boy is
um
will be the way that we uh ride it all
the way to Valhalla baby we're gonna
have three boys tearing up our [__]
house it's gonna be like a God damn host
nuclear Wasteland in our house basically
I mean it pretty much already is
I gotta ask yeah that's am I crazy or
doesn't it spawn new eggs doesn't they
spawn like more so maybe there will be a
new girl spawn soon a spawn like did you
think that do you think that this is
like a modern warfare what happened yeah
something like that it's like you would
just wait a little bit and it's gonna
spawn a new egg I think so but I've gone
through this whole process
that was like terrible expensive painful
the whole thing and now I they retrieved
the eggs so now I have Frozen
and it's it's six boys and the one girl
um I guess I could technically maybe
start from the beginning but that would
be like torture it's it's a nice torture
basically it was really a lot of effort
it's like I think it was two months just
to get to the point of retrieving the
eggs of like of shooting ultrasounds
every week and hormones it's crazy
seeing the doctor and it's crazy because
we got eight or seven or eight high
quality eggs which is a lot that's a lot
most people get like a couple and
they're all [__] boys
we'll see though I'm still feeling good
I'm still feeling good
mm-hmm
I think it's going to stick
but you know I'm happy either way that's
that's not yeah I know I just um
I think I need to be done with these
hormones driving me crazy
so there it is
all right an update there thank you what
time's the accent coach calling in I've
been they're they're standing by we
gotta do our ad and then we gotta go do
okay so let me thank our one sponsor
today native
[Music]
man I love me this product native as a
brand it doesn't get nicer it doesn't
smell better it doesn't get more natural
than metal
I love that in fact this uh sunscreen
SPF 30
is uh coconut and Barbados no coconut
and pineapple
coconuts and divorce
smells good not a flavor you don't eat
it it's not a scent all different
flavors you know what and it's starting
to get sunny and I find myself soaking
up Rays I do in the backyard
when you
when you can get it you know not getting
enough sunlight is uh
causes a lot of health problems for a
lot of people in the world so you gotta
get out there and get those Rays man and
I'll tell you what the sun's a [__]
[__]
part of my language
but why is it that the Sun
it's like it's killing us like you're in
the Sun for five minutes and you get
cancer I swear to god dude if you're in
the sun without sunscreen for five
minutes your skin looks like a goddamn
football by the time you turn
you know 50. you gotta put on sunscreen
more and more we're realizing that as a
civilization as people of this Earth
so that's why you need to get this
native sunscreen mm-hmm
uh natives quickly absorbing ultra sheer
hydrating and lightweight sunscreen
formula offers broad spectrum SPF 30
protection and UVA and UVB rays
that's a lot of rays
[Applause]
this is when I drive my hands are like
always in the Sun so I always put on
sunscreen I always put I keep this in my
car and put it on my oh on my hands and
ribs look at you yeah because it's like
it's actually just sitting in the sun
for an hour a day when I'm driving yeah
that that's enough time to damage your
skin big time you know
I'm a huge sunscreen guy I don't I don't
mess around you know
when we were at the uh Renaissance Fair
those Kit the boys of ours I was like
sunscreen I don't care how much you're
complaining going everywhere you know
that's love
all Native they hate it of course they
do all Native sunscreen is made with a
20 active zinc oxide formula that is
dermatologist tested and suitable for
sensitive skin all Native sunscreen is
made with oils derived from plants
uh that seal in skin moisture and is
vegan and cruelty free vegan
thank you well you cannot eat it I just
want to make that clear why would you
want to
well it does it smells great and it's
vegan
it's vegan and cruelty free choose from
one of native's three delicious but
subtle scents like coconut and Barbados
sorry I can't help it coconut and
pineapple this this one rose or Sweet
Peach and nectar
for your face and body or try they have
an unscented option for our uh unscented
kings and queens sensitive allergies
concepted yup yeah
yeah it's awesome with all Native
sunscreens you get protection from the
Sun that is free of chemical actives
like oxybenzone ox aux opticazone
container
Octonauts denotate
what everybody knows what that that
everybody knows octonautsate right here
it doesn't have that
there is no oxybenzone or oxytonoxate or
avobenzone
right which makes native uh sunscreen
compliant with the Hawaii act 104 which
was passed in effort to protect Hawaii's
reefs oh somebody was just asking about
that yeah this is Reef friendly
sunscreen okay
it's all happening at native
give your skin the protection it
deserves with natives of mineral
sunscreen go to nativedeo.com after dark
or use the promo code after dark at
checkout to get 20 off your first order
that's nativedeo.com
after dark or use the promo code after
dark at checkout nativedeo.com after
darker use the promo code after dark
thank you so much to Native we love you
please consider supporting our wonderful
[Music]
ah
all right so um
I feel like [__] today man I don't know
I feel like weird
you know maybe it's just Cinco de Mayo
something in the air about it
come on Dan let's hear it
[Laughter]
all right hey that's just not right all
right so we have an accent you guys know
that I struggle with my accents I mean I
feel that I've got my Southern accent
down let's be real
but not everybody in the world is
Southern
and that's how I portray them because I
have no other you know
I got no other tricks in the back here's
a meme from the subreddit for example
uh ever as you can see every state is
yep Southern California is normal
I see that New York has Godfather
Impressions so there's nothing out there
but everything else is uh Southern yeah
southern accent
and well sophisticated because we're
trying to broaden my horizons here so
because of that we are bringing in a
professional accent dialect coach to
help train me
uh
his name is Jack
and I'm gonna train today the British
accent
how did you guys find Jack
uh I found him just looking around I
found an article with uh interviews with
accent coaches in Hollywood so he popped
up
trains actors and stuff on shows okay
good
podcasts deadbeats
all the flavors we specified a jack that
Ethan could use help on my British
Southern and Italian I don't know why
you guys put Southern in here frankly
well
so let's talk maybe it is a little more
nuanced than that because I think it's
the bigger issue is that you think
anything up to like North Dakota is a
Southern accent right
um and so maybe we can maybe distinguish
like Midwest yeah but I'm not doing that
I'm not getting into all that southern
grow like I can't do it being on all
that now well I know I'll tell you what
man there's two kinds of people in this
world there's Maya and there's people
from California
I tell you what man I'm bringing out my
guns out to the lake anybody come here
fishing gonna catch one from me boy I'll
tell you what
and then there's people from California
like hey what's up dude do you want to
go to the library and study with me
all right let's bring in Jack here's
Jack you guys want to learn a little bit
about him let's see
Jack I'm watching your video I want to
see your promise to me before uh before
I uh introduce you here's your video
Wallace and I'm a dialect coach here in
Hollywood
okay so Jack how are you thank you for
calling in hi hello I'm doing well how
about to be today we're doing good so I
hear an English accent is that what's
happening that is correct are you
tricking me well how do I not wait and
find out exactly okay Jack hit me with
it really just a spy hit me with an
American accent
like what do you want me to say yeah
[Music]
say the English lost the war and they're
just a bunch of stuck up I don't know
yeah no I am actually from England but
I've been in the states for about 10
years now
well and so you have a have had a nice
Career Training and dialect to uh
actors and and the likes oh no they're
selling money yeah
let's go to the bathroom real quick
oh
ela's hairs are falling out and um
what's your credentials what's your
what's your background in terms of
accents and dialects and all that
yeah well in England you can do a
masters in this sort of thing so I got
that um in professional voice practice
and then I was in Chicago for a while I
was working with theater actors and then
made the big move out here to California
and so I've been working on film and TV
oh congratulations I'm glad that uh you
found your Niche there that's great
so these guys I I'm doing this against
my will I'll have you know
that's what they were kind of telling me
um I you know I haven't done too much
research on your amazing accents so I
would love to hear in your own words
how you feel about yourself yeah so I'll
be the first to admit that my my British
accent and my my Italian accent are a
bit wanting
but my Southern accent I feel is
completely authentic and just to be
clear your Italian accent is actually
just Marlon Brando from The Godfather
it's not really even Italian necessarily
well that's right is that not authentic
don't you come to me on this day
amazing teach me how to do an accent
you presumed to tell me on my own show
Tony
his name is Jack
do you think you hear that he said he
loved it oh you love it so that's yeah
just leave right now I think I think the
British the British one I'll be honest I
got a lot of trouble with that one let's
see oi
go great go great yeah
do you find the Lizzie and the Box Thing
offensive I don't wanna you know
I mean there's about to be a new person
tomorrow so you know
we're the new Kings tomorrow is that
what you said yeah the coronation Okay
so
she's yeah good it's not in a box yeah
right
um
so it's like uh
what What's with I got nothing
but my Southern accent now that's what I
like I kind of locked that up
good old Maga you ever heard of Donald
Trump he's kind of like you know he's
got a lot of good ideas about Mexicans
and them kind of immigrants and I tell
you what man I've been out on the lake
seen a boy out there with a fishing pole
took a couple shots at him you know what
I'm saying so that's why uh Southern
and whereabouts would you place that in
the South oh this accent it's kind of
just the bra it's kind of like everybody
outside of California
hmm be sounding like this
great
um what about the people inside of
California oh they sound like this
all of them yeah yeah just like this but
so where do we begin let's say let's
let's say let's start with the British
because I feel like I got nothing and I
really want to have a good British
accent
sure is there a particular phrase you
where would you like to use this is it
like at a restaurant or the pub is it
like in the Royal Palace like what what
sort of because there's more than one
British accent right I think my favorite
is like the peaky blinders
like Regional one but I I think yeah I
think I think I know what you're you're
looking for because well what options
are there there's like the Queens uh
English maybe you can give me some
examples and I'll tell you which one I
like
sure so with everything you could kind
of divide it into big groups and then
gets modern smaller and smaller so we
could get very specific and there are
kind of hundreds of hundreds to choose
from or we could go kind of broad
regions and the first big split is north
versus South so it's actually
flipped from America in that the
predominant accent that you hear around
is the southern accent and then you have
the northern exit I'm not sure if you
watched Game of Thrones at all I did yes
but a lot of the Starks had more of a
northern accent okay
um whereas
female one's head the southern accent so
the northern accent is the
less common one is it also considered to
be white trash like in America
it's more kind of City versus
Countryside okay so it's similar
and I say white trash with the love in
Edinburgh yeah
um but there are I think what you're
envisioning in your mind would be
something kind of Southern probably
London based
um and not not the palace version I
wouldn't mind having the queen's English
you know what I mean I think that's kind
of cool too but so so give me an idea of
like londoners uh versus like the
queen's English where are we at on that
yeah so there's this thing called
received pronunciation RP for short um
and basically someone decided that they
wanted everyone to sound the same and
they made up how people should sound and
that's kind of closer to how the Kings
or queen's English I guess it's Kings
again now
um is so your bowels are very precise
you want to make sure that you're not
going too far doing anything that would
be unseemly
um it's just very very precise whereas
as you get more kind of colloquial then
you start to slide into the vowels a bit
more
and there's a bit of relaxation I'm
feeling uh kind of the peaky blinders
stuff
great
um what what phrase might you say if you
were so let's say like this
Blinder nobody [__] so you know uh
what's a oi all the boys down at the
track are they collected all the
they we doing the tickets down at the
track boy
great yeah and peaky blinders they went
down to the racetrack right and they
they muscled out the old uh crew
you know
so I just want to get the character as
much as possible
um so maybe if we just take the phrase
we're collecting all the tickets okay
I'm at the track okay I like that I like
that
yeah so how would you say the first word
normally
it's in your own California we're we're
yeah weird
and so if you slow it down you've got
kind of an e followed by that Heavy R or
weird
well we don't want that Heavy R at the
end and we're just gonna replace it with
an uh but we still want the E for the
week
we are where
yeah yeah
what's the deal with Australians they go
for ER they go they do like a a sound
what does they always say
yeah no what do they say what do they
always say on below deck that we laugh
at oh oh
um
what is it
uh why am I blanking whatever whatever
sorry think on that okay okay we're what
where where
so no r at all just an uh instead where
where
[Laughter]
um
I try to remember the the beautiful
sentence we've created I think it was
like we're going to collect the tickets
we are we're getting the tick hits from
the race track brother
great so
off to a great start
of this weird
um so there's lots of things you could
do with this tea in the word getting if
you were just saying it casually in your
own accent it might be like getting with
a kind of D ish thing in the middle
we don't want that you can either put a
full tea in or you can completely drop
it so you could do getting or you could
do getting I like that one yeah I like
that one
yeah so we're getting
yeah oh that's it those experience those
go yeah but they raise their voice
yeah yeah or no yeah yeah yeah yeah
what was it it's there I can't remember
can you remember
they go uh
God damn it
all right it'll come to you yeah
but yeah so everyone we're getting so
well we'll break between the get and the
ink we're get in yeah yeah we're getting
we'll get it and remember no ER on the
Wii or the drop in there yeah no hard
arms exactly in this building and that's
a good policy regardless right
exactly yes
yeah we're getting we're getting tickets
are gonna be pretty similar to how you
would normally say it oh yeah they go
narrow the people knew yeah
because whenever we were whenever you
watch below deck like instead of saying
no they'll say nar no no thank you God
damn it I when I watch below deck I just
sit there the whole time going no no I
actually think I got it pretty good no
no
yeah can you hit me with your best nerd
uh no no
it's because the they use the middle of
their tongue to do that whereas an
American would use the back of the
tongue to make an ER so it's kind of
just the same action just so instead of
R it's just a little bit further forward
of oh no no no no that's not bad at all
no no no
so uh we're all over the world now let's
go back to England yeah yeah we're
getting these tickets down at the track
um so we're getting we've nailed
um tickets is going to be the same you
don't have to do anything with that
tickets I may say it American Trust Me
tickets
I mean I feel like you were trying to
not do it the way you would normally do
it I'm just all right let's see
what what where where
no no
so the way to get rid of this art if you
make some little finger guns put them in
your mouth okay that'll come out excuse
me
I'm not doing that bad
and then take them out and keep that
space well wow
so say for me we're getting tickets just
say that for me yeah we're getting
tickets we're getting we're getting
tickets
we're we're getting tickets we're
getting tickets we're getting we're
getting tickets
we're getting tickets we're getting
tickets you could do the G or you could
not do the G getting okay
we're getting tickets we're getting
tickets we're getting tickets we're
getting tickets
myself
yeah okay we're we're
getting we're getting tickets
yeah yeah where
only London we're getting we're getting
we're getting tickets yeah London wait
he said you say it like normal dad he's
going tickets
tickets we're getting tickets where
tickets tickets we're getting we're
getting tickets
doesn't feel right tickets doesn't feel
right I think they're a big quite like
forceful with that tea
soften the tea
we're getting two Hills
tickets just tickets tickets yeah that
sounds great tickets okay we're again we
are getting we're we're getting tickets
where
where oh my God where where where
getting tickets I feel like you're still
hitting that arm where I just know why
I'm going right where my mouth on the
other one to think about that might be
if you put a y in the middle and do we
uh we yeah okay
that's good we are
we are getting if you could just write
it out phonetically I feel like I could
do it yeah that was true yeah
getting tickets what's the difference
between that and where oh where uh the
the where versus Weir no like um
[Laughter]
all right Dan wrote it out phonetically
we are getting we are getting we are
getting tickets
yeah and if you change the T to like an
apostrophe instead getting getting oh
yeah we are getting tickets oh okay hey
we are we're getting somewhere we uh
yeah
we are ending tickets
oh you wrote yeah
I missed the G yeah oh we're we're
getting tickets
[Music]
I think my G is just not working I'm
afraid
so I might come up to you at the
racetracks and be like Ethan what are
you doing and you would say we're
getting tickets
we're getting we're getting tickets
[Music]
yeah and I think you can play around
with intonation a little bit as well
okay dude let's do this one something
else
um what's his name Shelby
I'm author I'm Arthur [__] Shelby of
the peaky blinders yeah
so I'm our author I'm also [__]
Shelby yeah
okay I've got to write in a fake version
of this and I just want you to thank you
so much he's writing it out phonetically
for me
yes uh I'll copy it over to you once you
send it where
oh yeah where what's his last name
Shelby
wig we're getting tickets
where where where where where oh that's
perfect yeah
we're getting Shelby what's wrong with
my getting I don't know is it right
what's wrong with my getting getting I
think I think it's just that you're
going too much of a pitch variation
between the two things yeah yeah getting
getting almost like you're combining it
I feel like you're saying like you're
more like in with it
we're getting tickets
[__] Shelby
the M on that first bit
oh I'm oh I'm off the [__] Shelby
okay that's good that wasn't bad yeah
oh I'm off the [__] Shelby mate
where's my [__] money how much you're
only 20 quid
yeah I think we're making some
improvements for sure what one of the
things that we're definitely doing is
getting rid of those R's which is what
it is
[Applause]
the is the r like kind of like is that
really one of the core differences
between like an American accent and a
British accent like it's one of the big
differences for most of the English
accents you'll find places in the the
West country near Bristol uh if you've
seen any of the Harry Potter that's how
Hagrid talks or any of the Lord of the
Rings that's how a lot of the hobbits
talk okay
um where they have their Arts but it's
only in a specific region where they
have those
um otherwise it's what about like a
regular person from London
uh-huh then you only say an R if the
next
thing is about
otherwise you don't
let's see the next sound I will
literally never ever forget that my
whole I'll never remember
the title of your show
H3 podcast
the H3
yeah and which which brand of the H3 is
this one after Dark
exactly so we don't want either of those
R's in there the one after after
it's the H3 podcast
after after dark
could use the same one in after
dark after dog yeah that one yeah all
right we need to work on something like
oh give me something like really
obscenely English
it's the H3 podcast
the dog after
yeah so we're gonna have three R's in a
row it's gonna be pod podcast
after dark how do I but okay so here
let's nail down a specific phrase and
then
uh something about
um
something about Bob's your uncle I'm
taking suggestions at the moment
let's go down to the uh
something about uh
I like B I like beans on toast there you
go ordering beans yeah I think that's a
great phrase that's what I need yeah
Okay add Lux let me try
I'd like I'd lock beans on toast players
wow okay okay I can see that yo applying
everything that we've put in yes
um hey uh
I like some beans on toast y'all hear
about them beans on toast them English
are crazy with them beans I ain't never
heard of something
I put a ridiculous version in the chat
box for someone to send to you and I
just want you to read that and see what
happens again I'm not I'm not holding my
breath necessarily but I'd love to just
see oh
or would like I lock some beans on top
toast please
and lock some beans on top please
so
um the first two if you take your lips
and let them round a little bit and go I
I I
rather than I I I I
that's great yeah and then could you
keep them there for like I like oh wait
no do I hit them no that that was great
yeah
[Laughter]
good luck some
yeah some sort of great beans is regular
beans beans regular to you oh it locks
on beans beans beans
yep and then round it again
and now this is the fun one
toe toast
oh that you would normally have in
America
like the for me
say again
you see an uh like in the word the for
me
then can you say uh
can you join the two together
toast yeah and let your lips round a lot
oh toast that was it yeah
I like I I like I like some beans on
pairs
we gotta shed that twang on the beans
okay wait wait you know what we let
Southerners like our baked beans
the southern is comfort-free
that's right y'all English wouldn't
understand
laughs
a lot a lot some ah a lot so
um beans
you know when you were doing that with
your lips it actually helped quite a lot
oh is it better I mean it didn't sound
Southern
again do me a favor ask Chachi BT to
write
a sentence the most English
sounding sentence for us you know uh
this is a moment to ask Chachi what
about Israeli accent is that something
that you know
um I've worked with people either with
it or trying to change it to something
else oh yeah yeah okay how do I rid of
it
and I think you should get rid of it
um but one of the things about Hebrew is
that it only has a
um I think it's fine yeah
that's awesome yeah that's awesome five
vowels
um that you use whereas in American
English the 16. oh
so sometimes one sounds
like
something that's actually too in
American so for example the E
and the E the Hebrews kind of between
those two
and so it's trying to separate it into
when it's supposed to be an e in like
sleep or in it as it is so that's like
one of the challenging areas I never
even thought about it like that
sorry
it came through for us did it so the
most advanced AI in the world has
crunched the data with millions of data
points and here is the uh short
paragraph or sentence it's generated for
us blimey blimey after a day at the
office this knackered blow could
certainly fancy a cup of wait okay a cup
of some bit because with some biscuits
while watching the telly followed by a
Swift visit to the local pub for a
cheeky pint with his mates before
grabbing some fish and chips on the way
home we're going back in time but the
great thing is we've got to hear all
your possible accents that's awesome
guys I don't know I I don't know if this
is a lost cause
it's great let's just pick out a couple
of the words in here blimey I just uh I
just sent it to you in the chat so you
can represent blind me after a long time
you could certainly fancy a couple of
biscuits well watching telly followed by
a Swift visit to the local pub for
cheeky pint with his mates before
grabbing some fish and chips on the way
home wow do you feel that's around this
sentence I don't know
time no it sounds like the perfect day
honestly
um let's look at one of the words in
here because
it it's going to be tricky and I think
but I think I I have faith that at least
one of you could do it oh yeah somebody
in here so the the word is f-a-n-c-y
fancy fancy
I'll tell you what boy I like them fancy
type not fancy y'all that kind of a
fancy City
now can you say the word f-a-t for me
fat
so that same sound that you use in that
that ah is what we need in this word
rather than gliding a fair in anything
we just want Fancy
Fancy Fancy Fancy
fat fat
fancy fair so yeah you can take the tea
off just fancy oh no t fancy fat that
was funny yeah fancy fancy
bam not bad
thanks a cup a cup of biscuits while
watching the teddy yeah a Cuppa and some
biscuits a cup of a cup and some beer
skit
boy
blimey mate yeah after a long day at the
office boy this knackered old bloke I'll
tell you what under God cause certainly
fancy one of them cups a tea and a
couple of biscuits it might be a lost
cause
hey do me a favor pull me that tea nice
and slow like the lashes
you know time moves slow in the South
out here
in the south of England yeah yes exactly
exactly
we have discovered that's right you know
what I think it's not happening let's
try Italian yeah yeah what about Italian
it's not happening it's just nice
do we have uh a beautiful chat GPT
created yes
or something about Fredo breaking my
heart I got something that's what I was
about to say are we talking about an
Italian accent are we talking about a
old gangster movie yeah Italian gangster
movie okay so okay that's more like a
Brooklyn accent wouldn't it be something
like that
yeah
I believe I believe I believe in America
has made me my fortune
Americans made me the man I am today
can you do exactly the same but without
the growl
that's that's the whole thing the ground
you're shifting some other things at the
same time and they're not they're not
wrong necessarily free Fredo Fredo Fredo
yo it sounds like Mario
brother and I love you
but don't ever take it as sides against
the family again
so we've gone back to the the motherland
which is great
um yeah let's do the motherland then
one of the words I want you to just do
one little substitution and that's hard
pretty good I put a little thing in the
chat it sounds better with the growl
though don't you think
I love you that's exactly
the same thing happens in brother
instead of brother
brother
you're my older brother I love I love
you you could be a merrier too the
English with with peace and love of
course I just it's not accessible to me
it's really hard you know but my chance
for learning the English accent I think
was buried when uh
the queen was
rip
inappropriate from the eve of the
coronation come on how do we feel about
King Charles are we a fan of King
Charles do we think he could fill the
show using the Royal Wii I'm asking you
I'm asking you
I'm asking the individual Londoner
um
he is here he got that sausage fingers
huh you've seen those meaty Little
Things
I haven't really paid questions deep
ly I'll show you I'll just show you it's
just interesting it's not related to our
accent training obviously but it is
atmospheric I would say King Charles
fingers
he got some sausage like little sausages
bro like breakfast sausages I saw uh for
the coronation people are making sausage
finger sandwiches
oh my God can you see those little
things little uh mittens oh man
could put that on a piece of bread that
might be a condition oh it's definitely
a condition okay I think it's there's no
question about that she's in everything
everything where all at once
all right I'm I'm actually feeling the
Italian one uh let's yeah it's a
progress with that for sure
um maybe you want to go into a
restaurant and order like
pesto or pizza or something okay uh hold
on let's show
you're my oh the how did you say brother
again
[Music]
Olivia you've sat here with us all these
years and never mentioned
that's your own grandmother comes from
the motherland dally
she's back there right now actually
visiting wow
yeah grandma no no you tell your
grandmother that
if she if she's thinking about stepping
up to the dawn
there's only enough space in this city
for the one of us I'll let her know
Paulie
I love you Grandma you're my you're my
Grandma I love you
yeah how you do that beautiful eye you
just did in Grandma creme I love you are
you using the back of your tongue are
you using the front of it
front yeah
for sure let's do you don't even think
to call you don't you don't even you
don't even think to cuddle me
god father
instead you come into my house on the
day of my daughter to be married
and you ask her to me to do it you're
asking me to do today Ahmad for money
[Laughter]
yeah hit me with that yeah
you don't even think to call me
Godfather Godfather
[Music]
instead you come into my house
on the day of my daughter
what happened
instead you coming to my house my brain
shows me him like on a map going
somewhere else in the world when he
switches you're doing more poorly you
know you're doing my Paulie you're gonna
take care of your Don
dude I I hate to say it but I think um I
think Jack is totally lost
oh I think I I don't know that I don't
know that this Tempest is something that
could be uh quelled
contained yes I don't think so
I mean it's like trying to teach uh
I mean
trying to teach trying to teach a
gorillas
[Music]
I feel like we made a couple of things
that progress here and there we go
so here's chat's uh uh Italian for you
Eric hit me with the music Zack
the music I feel like it throws you off
yeah yeah
exactly we got a little a job for you
and if you do it right
maybe someday it'll be a man
just remember
if someone get in your way don't be
afraid to show at Emma who's a boss
actually it wrote a boom that's gotta be
racist oh my God have you ever heard of
Italia phobia it is a real thing and uh
we do need to be sensitive of it
for sure for sure I mean Lady Gaga
can you can you read that sentence for
me
yeah I don't have it here I'll put it
into the I'll put it in yeah I thought
you did a pretty good job oh really
really
[Applause]
we got that little job for you and if
you do it right maybe someday it'll make
you a man
just remember people are saying Italian
leprechaun
just remember is somebody getting your
way don't be afraid to show them who's a
boss
forget the only word I wanna get you to
alter
really is to a job and I want it to be
job rather than job job
exactly
we got the Little Joe over for you
if you ever do it right maybe summer day
you'll even be a man like a [__]
just remember if somebody gets it out of
your way don't be afraid to show no
matter who's a boss
you can definitely be in the Mario
sequel
wow I think that is a win I'll take that
as a win
he's so cool
so bada bing bada boom that's not really
an Italian thing is it
wrote that and I feel it
it's choosing off of stereo what about
Russia does that interest you
bro
from Russia Russia
Vladimir Putin
Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin
that is not bad yeah
I mean that the accent
well okay then let's you rate my one
accent that I think is fantastic okay I
have an accent that I think shines above
them all
that of course I'm talking about uh the
girl boys you know what I'm saying you
ever been down south Jack you ever been
down to Georgia about them about them
times now
I actually lived in Mississippi for a
while oh little girl oh you're a good
old boy from the south I like that you
ever come down on the Delta take a
little Steamboat down there just enjoy
at a slow time slow like molasses
nice warm summer day mm-hmm
had me something sweet tea and a ghetto
that's right
have me at one of them uh
what do you call them like the those
[__] balls
that the Chris Hansen got canceled for
oh an antebellum ball have me one of
them Antebellum balls right yeah
right okay go ahead so so yeah one out
of ten well I feel like you take us on a
tour of the South wait okay with the
accent yeah you know I'm inclusive I do
that intentionally of course yeah yeah
so there are times when you kind of feel
like you'll maybe in the Appalachians
and then you you kind of via over to
Texas round to Georgia back well I'm a
good I represent the South you know what
I'm saying it's
personally my favorite is dark Nathaniel
klansman where he buries bodies you know
all right that was probably your
exciting moment I tell you what man
sometimes I sit out here on the porch
and I get to think
dark dogs you know sometimes out here
there's nothing to do but think
sometimes the storms roll in keep you
bound to your house for week two on in
the waters they follow the rivers they
rise up and I tell you what man I tell
you some of them Rivers rise up some of
them bodies rise up too
ain't nothing I'm proud of but I'll tell
you what boy got a couple [__] got a
couple of things under my floorboard
when them Rivers rise so I get a little
anxious when it rains because Dark
Secrets come out when the time goes up
[Music]
yeah I definitely think the pitch is
your friend you ever you ever sit on the
porch and
see the country light up by the
lightning lot
make you think about all this here is it
God who put us all here no
someone much darker than that what is
God
it's a joke
God won't put me here on this hill on
Earth
I tell you what I grew up but I grew up
with my good old friend
Jeremiah
me and Jeremiah used to be real close
like
we used to run through the fields
we used to
we used to shoot at deer and the in the
field I
one day Jeremiah come home to me he'd be
close friends real close
Jeremiah one day he come home he said I
kissed your sister
I wasn't too kind about that because
I'll tell you what man I've been kissing
my sister
what's your argument
that's my sister and they won't gonna be
reprogramming with her Jeremiah that's
gonna be me
[Music]
so I took Jeremiah out back told him we
were going to sleep some sweet tea
and I wish for it in his ear Jeremiah
cross the line this time Big Brother
and I did something I regret I'm not
proud to say it but I put my hands on
his neck
wow she's a lot left his his eyes
the last breath exited his mouth
as I looked on his lifeless body I
realized what I had done but there we go
going back at this point
I could see
[Music]
[Laughter]
I could tell there was no rut going back
at this point
saw the clouds rolling in across the
field it was coming in ready for some
rain
but I thought if I got to live a good
life here for my sister I got to get rid
of this body
she gonna wonder where Jeremiah went
he's a good friend he's been around for
a long time people be asking questions I
gotta make sure that body got gun good
gone
so did me trenched down up in the fields
real deep talking I took the tractor the
John Deere
[Laughter]
I took my pop I took my daddy's John
Deere
and I start digging
and most by most people calculation they
say about six feet enough but I kept
thinking
and maybe was maybe it wasn't I was
digging to hide the body maybe I was
digging my own shame trying to hide it
don't have to ever face it again
I tell you that John Deere went out
deepest went about as deep as my shame
down to the Devil Himself
and when I put Jeremiah's corpse I wrote
it right in there the devil lick his ass
so deep
and he did I swear to God
as I filled in that ditch with my good
friend Jeremiah I said
all right let's go never gonna be the
same around here
went home the rain started to poured
lightning hit the fields
like a shock from God
to see the trees shaking out there in
the feet
[Laughter]
[Music]
I like to say that was the last time I
took a man's life but it was only the
first turned out I had an appetite for
peoples sending people out down to a
real deep grave
what's up man there's some kind of the
darkness a hole in me couldn't be filled
by nothing else
and I wanted this kind of man I was kind
of I wasn't kind enough murder but it
was a hole a deep hole inside of me
couldn't be filled up no it'll kind of
work
started with Jeremiah turned out the
next one was
Jim Bob
I don't like to talk a bit and Jen Bob
hurt not it feel it hurt too bad Jim Bob
a good man
but I tell you man something happened
when them light just switch off on my
eyes and I see Jim Bob and I just think
this man belonging to dirt down with the
Devil Himself
[Music]
so I'll tell you I admit Jim Bob's jazz
oh
[Music]
I met Jim Bob one day uh
humid summer day out there in the fields
he's picking he's picking uh all the
crops the Combs getting ready for
Harvest
it was a tough harvest season you know
the the disease came ate most of our
cramps hard time for us farmer type
but come around to you and Bob come
around saying hey you boys look thirsty
you boys look like you're gonna have
some kind of drink dehydrate
I did one I was thirsty take no truth
about that but I was thirsty for
something else
he didn't want to know the truth and I
didn't want to face it either I'd
already taken one man's life
I was about to take another
I took Jim Bob into my house while we
had ourselves some of them iced tea
something just woke me
he was a good man a good Christian bar
a game that iced tea I watched the cubes
swirl around his glass like the last
Embers of his life
this great flame that was Jim Bob about
to be flickered about to flicker to the
end
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
's last moment here on this Earth he
didn't even see you coming
ah
I hate to think about Jim Bob what I did
to him wasn't right
but I'll tell you since you asked
[Laughter]
sat down right next to him
I put a little bit of a sedative in his
iced tea you know the kind that just
make you sleep nice and peaceful
well he drank his tea while I tell you
what passed right there on the couch
went to sleep sweet like an angel
he looked so peaceful when he slept like
that the last time he'd ever sleep I
tell you man
what is the difference between death and
sleep I wonder
as I sat there looking at uh Jim Bob
taking a nice little sleep there
because what I tell you when I took that
knife and dug it into his side
I tell you he didn't wake up
he just kept on sleeping
and I wondered to myself what is the
difference
I just took me alive and yet this man
couldn't even wake up the pace faced me
in the eyes
I'll tell you Jim Bob was a good man
around the community his family gonna
know what was going on
his mama come around talked about hey
you've seen Jim Bob I say I ain't seen
Jim Bob around here you know I ain't
seen Jim Bob ages we was close
that was very good thank you so much
this show will Premiere next Thursday so
yeah uh yeah what did you think about my
accent I think you have another career
as an a e documentary
[Applause]
honestly he's like genuine note I feel
like for you that pitch really helps you
stay in a certain accent um
so this version of your certain exit
when you when you do it down here then
that kind of helps you stay in one place
rather than switching between things and
the same with your like Godfather
because you've got that extra vocal
quality happening I'll tell you how much
you have to stay you say it's down down
there and that's what I saw when I said
Jim Bob's body I said stay down there
not again because sometimes this the the
soul is the body's boss trying to escape
and put Jim Bob down in that there hoe I
said stay down low there
stay downloaded
sorry guy
I appreciate you uh sometimes I get I
get uh
in the words of Tupac it's just dead
homies uh speaking uh through my mouth
it's lost in the sauce a little bit
all right jack everybody
thank you so much you know I appreciate
it I know this wasn't an easy assignment
for you but uh clearly you're very
talented and I'm you know the The Faults
of me should not reflect on uh you as a
coach surely no I think there's
potential there and I definitely think
with either as well the the hidden
talent like that yeah
chat loves you yeah Chad thought you
were a sweetheart for tolerating me so
thank you Jack thank you I appreciate
you having me and uh thank you so much
people if you want uh uh if you guys
want you can hit him up at
accentcoachjack.com
check on all platforms that's awesome
accent accent coach Jack we'll put the
link in the description you guys can
check it out
worked on Westworld Fargo really more
wow Fargo that's an interesting one I
love it yeah it's the new season that's
coming out
this month I think oh I love that show
so good
yeah all right jack take care thanks for
calling in appreciate it for having me
all right all right thank you
have a good night
sorry about that
yeah I didn't work at all that was just
not good
I feel like your accents might be worse
I think they're worse I think they are I
love that I thought that was so funny
well you know I looked the thing that
got me is I looked up and Jack was so
politely and seriously listening I
thought I just keep going for him um
you know
someone said he looked so confused
oh [__] all right sorry about that Jack
uh you didn't deserve that
just like Jim Bob didn't preserve what
came to him he's a good man didn't
deserve that no sir
tell you man
he's a good old boy that Jim Bob shame
what happened in
shame what happened to him was go ahead
Zach shame what happened to him sister
too she came looking for Jim Bob you
still got more in you
she came around looking for Jim Bob I
told her well I ain't seen him you won't
come in for a drink though and y'all
know how that goes
[Music]
all right thank you guys
is that all improvised
what did you think uh no you actually
killed him
I think it'd be crazier if I wrote that
that's wild you improvise that I gotta
give you props for that thank you yeah
that was pretty beautiful thank you I
just Dak was moved so it was nice
[Music]
all right let's move on let's forget all
about this accent thing
good idea in theory
the English one is so hard for me I
don't know why it's really hard for me
too it's like just not I just don't
understand it
and I work with somebody pretty much
every day with a very thick English
accent
and I I love it I love it I love
listening to it
boy [__] blinders I wish I could do
it because that would be like the most
useful accent you know to having my
repertoire
all right happy Cinco de Mayo everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
a little better
foreign
[Music]
that's funny
Chad gbt how could you even what would
be pretty could never I would like to
know I'm gonna ask chat ask Jazzy BT to
write GPS uh a monologue of a southern
man thinking to himself reminiscing
about the time he had to kill his best
friend Jim Bob for sleeping with her
sister because he was in love with the
sister in the style of True Detective
season one oh yeah yeah okay now I'm
interested I'll narrate it what we could
do is take the whole uh transcript of
the when you were telling it and tell it
to continue the story oh [__] that'd be
crazy someone's gotta annotate all that
though
uh yeah Dan is that okay
asking well in my opinion the you know
bit already kind of went on too long so
if we were to do a chat GPT thing and
then you were to like narrate it it
would kind of just we would just be
doing that same bit again and what the
[__]
yeah that's the don't talk Dan button
what the [__] is this dude I got this
[__] I got inspired by Stephen Crowder
dude this is [__] up Dan don't talk I
hit the [__] button silence
all right now right into chat gbt I
don't have to ask you so many times
I'll button you again brother don't make
me
oh did you hear about the no Crowder
get a button for his co-host the
leprechaun uh when he wanted him to stop
talking so he could have the last word
he had a button that he would pushed it
turned on a light oh my God and so I got
inspired by it and I we installed my own
button is that okay for you Dan
it's really really [__] bright like I
can't see
could you at least just turn off the
light
like I won't talk can I can we turn off
the light you're talking now if you
maybe if you stop talking I'll turn off
the button
okay you can turn the light off
silence
oh there's more but there was there
another Crowder update that you sent was
that new
what is this
the fighter and the kid wait hold up
hold the phone isn't this the is this
the Schwab hate subreddit
yeah it's this dedicated to his podcast
but you can see him give the shut up
Dave button oh yeah you can see him oh
no way yeah
so wait he did the button to Callan oh
my god dude he just bitched
dude I love that Callum thinks he's an
alpha and Crowder just buttoned his ass
into silence I need that one more time
you can hear it click too you can hear
it
I love Crowders like I'm in the zone man
don't [__] me up ladies
[Laughter]
is the [__] best parents can force
them to keep the cookies
wow that was amazing
ladies
what's so good is he thought he was
being funny so he was trying to shut him
up to finish his stupid ass bit right
there yeah I love that
foreign
oh my God I didn't know that's that's
interesting to me that Brian got bitched
out with the button
well he seems to be the Dave replacement
so oh callum's the day replacement he's
already buttoning him yeah I mean it was
probably part of the deal to be frank
hey you Callan is such a gross [__]
loser for button if he was already not
gross enough and teamed up with Crowder
and Wild
just like sealed the deal
um oh yeah speaking of crowder
um
there here's an old article of Crowders
that I thought was fantastic this is
published
2015 he wrote as I'm a guy and I'll
never bad mouth my wife
I mean either
my wife is such a pain in the ass you
said as we were changing in the gym
locker room
you know how it is he finished blankly I
stared at him cocking my head sideways
like a befuddled Mastiff
but even is that
it's a dog like a it's like a dog
no I don't really know he said as I
finish dressing myself and walked out
you could hear a pin drop the gentleman
had certainly never heard nor expected
to hear a response like that from one of
the guys for as long as he'd lived this
oh never mind I'm gonna go ahead and say
right now yep you made this all up yep I
mean it wouldn't blow his mind if he's
like no I don't you could hear a pin
drop and then everyone clapped that
somebody came up and gave me a hundred
dollar bill he was like
wow
um tip of them a hat to you sir for
standing up for your wife
I was about to do a funny joke right
okay let's not steal the pillow
and then everybody clap I guarantee this
never happened
and then everybody clap and gave 100
bucks thank you Zach
thank you Dan that's great that was a
great
that
you're distracting
we have a it's not as slick
I love the button though so he goes he
goes uh as I finish dressing myself and
walked out you could hear a pin drop oh
yeah I've read that I think that's sad
also he needs to do some squats
Stephen Crowder
when men get together they moan about
their wives the commentary provided on
marriage between groups of men is
typically one from a Viewpoint that
assumes marriage to be Life's greatest
most unfun mistake not only is it often
as disingenuous as Joe Biden's hairline
bro are you [__] actually consider
yourself a comedian
Joe Biden's hairline
to see that in writing like that's such
a bad joke right like exactly yeah you
wrote that and then decided yeah I'm
keeping that is this is this giving you
like like erotic Vibes at all fanfic
Yeah well yeah he told him to do some
squats right like the locker room he's
like here's how it goes are you gonna go
I told him do some squads
and then we realize as we kept talking
about our wives
the electricity wasn't between the lies
between us husbands we went in the sauna
together
start kept talking about our wives and
the sauna
decided to drop my towel
um
I said to my friend don't you drop your
towel too get comfortable in here Sears
sauna
saw his big old dick come furling out
like a goddamn like a goddamn Deep Sea
scroll
[Music]
and I'll tell you the sea was deep that
day my friend
all right we don't need to go down that
hole again
uh but yeah as disingeness is Joe
Biden's hairline firstly there may be
some people out there who actually
believe their wife to merely be the old
ball and chain
this is so [__] awesome
he's like my wife who I chose wrong
won't even put on gloves and put on
toxic medicines up my dog's ass while
she's pregnant
to you I say you are a loser not only
are you a loser for dishonoring the
woman who is now an extension of
yourself but you're a loser for picking
someone you who you hate having to
become home every night this is like
literally crazy
what kind of an idiot are you to marry a
person that you think's a [__]
this is him he's talking to himself
doesn't work either
these same people are shocked when I
don't chime in on their urine ate and
moan Fest regarding their old maids
such a good guy that Stephen Crowder is
man we don't deserve him
imagine actually thinking I married
somebody better than myself imagine
looking forward to discussing anything
and everything with my wife because she
actually helps me make better decisions
to ultimately transform my life into
more than the selfish pile of crap I was
before her crazy I know
hold your nose though because here comes
the really cold water I actually love my
in-laws too
well I'm sure they love you back after
all this [__]
actually they're the ones that leaked
the video
the in-laws yeah they said we've been
hiding Crowders abusive behavior for
years
from his in-laws
awesome oh
now I realize that there are some people
who generally hate their spouse and that
said it really is it is sad Stephen it
is ever more often not I find that men
fall under category number two those
that actually love their wife just as
much as I do but are afraid to speak up
are you [__] stupid what is he
talking yo I love my I love my wife but
I'm just too I'm afraid to say it out in
public the guys are gonna think I'm lame
if I say hate my wife
yeah I hate my [__] life she sucks
gay that's so like
who are you hanging out with Stephen
those that actually loves their wives as
much uh but are afraid to speak up
because it's become commonplace in
modern society man cave of fakery
men get together and they complain about
their wives because that's what they
feel they're supposed to do it says
phony as your frat buddy stupid tribal
tattoos and everybody knows it
bro again you got some strange company
brother
yet they do it anyway
because just like the dummies who took
up smoking to fit in back in the high
school
bro you were smoking a cigar in front of
your pregnant wife dude the [__]
these guys want to make sure that they
have a spot in the cool kids table
pathetic
here's my challenge to real men out
there it's very simple if you have a
good marriage talk can I get some
atmosphere exact what are you feeling
clown show
okay
you got it maybe some honking sounds as
well
here's my challenge to the real men out
there
very simple if you have a good marriage
talk about it if you love your wife say
it if some [__] tells you that you're
merely a newlywed or that you're still
just too young to understand correct
them
open-handed slaps to the face are
preferred now hit the wait wait
hold on I gotta move it
thank you
you get the idea
ages like milk bro this is so
embarrassing what the [__]
is there a video about this no so there
it is uh Steven Crowder ladies and
gentlemen
the man who will never bad mouth uh his
wife
that's the title
and thank you by the way to
uh Chrissy Sherlock my goodness thank
you
so generous
all right let's see we got now Google
now you guys are [__] in the head for
this one
it says I'm 42 on Google did we talk
about this already
yeah we talked about it yesterday on the
show
[Music]
did it is it fixed yet
37 eat it I still don't know who this is
who is this
okay so it's a him it's about him yeah I
just want to know who who is he I just
want to know he's a tick tocker that was
you five years ago
really it just doesn't look like me at
all
I see it you guys are demons for this
[Music]
um
here's a video of uh
H3 podcast at the Mecca
it's kind of fun let's see
kind of cursed
is this me
is that me it looks like that that's 37
year old you this doesn't look wait
that's Zach
no it's not that doesn't look anything
that's not a different person the um
quality of the faces in this whole post
very wildly like some look exactly like
a b and Lena's is really funny too
it's like oh that's Lina I don't that's
like Ryan Reynolds maybe I'll tell you
what boy something went wrong and when
you were in the oven
yeah the temperature wasn't right or
something yeah
I don't know if yeast Ian and Sam
Alfredo what are you eating dude
this is Olivia
Dan I mean I don't see it cool that's a
cool outfit
nice one Dan I just don't see Dan in it
you know you're not actually showing the
outfits by the way well what does it
really matter and that was kind of not
the point of the post Jimmy Lee right
here I was I was waiting for you I want
to show this to you okay
fresh and fit uh there's a new clip
that's a new one it's really good it's
not about me but it's okay it says a lot
about this guy's psyche just listen to
this and tell me what you think
I'm down [__] that [__] I'm gonna
exercise The Leverage you want to be
with a guy like me you need to be at
your [__] Pride oh wow
he's like about to cry January
[__] [__] I I actually at his favorite
point I actually feel bad because he's
just so damaged
yeah he doesn't seem
you're not up this is down bad dude he's
screaming like that that seems pretty
down only thing that's up is this [__]
audio it sounds horrible true okay
and accept you [__]
does he know that the opposite of love
is not hate it's apathy he does not
because he's showing that he cares quite
a bit right
it's like one girl broke his heart and
he hasn't got over it dude
embarrassing you want to pull a guy like
me what does that mean yeah you you're
not that successful like we found out
coconuts and Barbados is the one that
paid for this whole operation oh no no
coconut say you're divorced
I'm not divorced yet coconut as of right
now I still stand coconutty Walter yeah
he hasn't said anything incriminating
yet because he just hasn't said anything
valid valid points [__] Halo figuring
out my life it's okay to play Halo bro
it's fine you know what I mean
you're 18 it's okay man we all go
through hard times you don't have to be
so hard on yourself Myron
you should talk to someone talk you talk
do you have a therapist you have someone
that you can be open and honest with
[__]
[__] I hope I mean he probably is on
open honest with coconuts and Barbados
but it's probably like talking to a
puppet or talking to the wall you know
it's like uh what was that a diary it's
like a diary it doesn't talk back but
it's good to vent to
sometimes it tells you about what day it
is
it's like it reminds you it's Wednesday
at the top of the page
[Music]
okay that's helpful information thank
you
but I just feel that man you need you
need professional help brother
[__] Halo you're still angry about
high school girls not wanting to [__]
you how old is she that's crazy like
genuinely how old is he it looks in his
40s
he's probably about mid 30s I guess he's
35. okay okay brother
that was 20 years ago and you're still
angry that high school girls wouldn't
[__] didn't want to talk to it's time to
move on dude
it's no way to live your life
[__] would have taken me so now that
I'm up you're down [__] that [__] I'm
gonna exercise they're not all down by
the way yeah who is it you're just
choosing you're choosing to date like
super young girls that don't have a lot
going for them so you can feel like
Superior that you have leverage it's
actually what he says this is some real
pathetic [__] dude
looks like he's about to have an
aneurysm and look at the vein in his
forehead this man is just been through
too much no [__] would have taken me
and even now that might be true yeah
I might actually I'm sorry you just seem
mean like you don't seem like someone
who's nice
that's how I feel about it [__] out of
here what about this makes you think
you're down [__] that [__] I'm gonna
exercise The Leverage you want to be
with a guy like me you need to Bear your
[__] Prime what does that mean I hate
that
I think he's saying a woman being at her
prime
I think he's saying I don't know what he
means and I feel like it's disgusting
whatever teenager like go to the gym I
don't know yeah in their Prime like
fertile like 18 prob teenagers yeah yeah
a teenager gross Prime puss says
oh don't say that I hate that that's the
worst thing I've ever heard
you got some problem s
keemstar
no you've done enough to the world
let's not stack on top of that kill I
think with the prime thank you for the
prime fuzz
oh [__] all right listen we keep
expanding our crew topics Ela
um and we're trying to be as inclusive
as possible did Hassan get added to this
one or is this one we looked at
yesterday
what do you mean career topics
well for example here this is the one we
looked at yesterday guys yeah I thought
you said you want to talk about it with
Ela
oh
okay well it's it's uh you know everyone
has their forbidden topics mine is
forbidden topics this one doesn't make a
lot of sense to me it's Philly Nick
ocado and Hiking those I get
by post Malone I don't understand yeah
yours is Trisha
uh Ian's is Kanye West
so highlight I don't understand the oh
cause he's got a p
oh this one took me a while so Lena's is
Benjamin Franklin and I was like what
does that mean and then I remembered it
was the dude from the stream right baby
yeah who was drafted that was like
putting his arm around her oh
cheese for love that's good you skipped
down I think Yeah dance isn't that good
oh Jimmy Lee audio crackle that one's
true
uh Wales that one's good right Olivia
the whales Haley Beaver yeah
Zach has a lot Clayton's Klein water
revival
dude the only fans is the real ones Zach
this [__] will not even not
exactly Zach won't even Zach won't even
touch that one what is only fans mean
Zach
exactly exactly that one is like
that one's real real forbidden oh that
one's even more forbidden than the climb
water revival very interesting
hmm
and yogurt I mean you know it's a
cottage cheese or is that yogurt
uh
that's just that's Greek yogurt here's
the thing about Greek yogurt
Cameron's is Ed sheering
cheering cheering cheering is that true
Cameron you just hate him right
yeah why do you hate them so much right
now I think it's yeah I did some soul
searching about the hairstyle no it's
it's when I worked at a restaurant they
would [__] play his music all the
goddamn time so he's like
ingrained in my mind it's like
psychological torture at Guantanamo Bay
yeah and then look at his [__] face
I'm sorry I know I know I'm so awesome
I don't get it my only problem is just
the hairstyle like I just think and the
tattoos people should outgrow this thing
the worst tattoos on Earth these shoes
are rainbow colors no they're awful and
they're everywhere I mean he is the
proverbial redheaded stepchild
I can feel my blood pressure Rising
looking at it in his eyes right now this
is not good it seems like he looks nice
though I'm sure he's yeah yeah he's
sweet I'm sure he's a fine kind he seems
like outside of the meme I'm sure he's a
fine guy and everything but he just just
being Overexposed to the mediocrity of
his music just it really gets them but
you think he's mediocre yeah and just
like an idiot honestly idiot he's a
dumbass Lego house was
well ABS is Michael Jackson which uh I
don't know if you saw but we all right
we had a further development with
Michael Jackson Another a run-in if you
would Roderick
but we're over that now right AB
yeah don't push
these should be things that will haunt
they'd be for the rest of his career
project yeah these two things all you
got to do is denounce him you're good
okay I'm not going there again
yeah
tragic you know you're better off just
playing it safe and denouncing him
I saw people being like Oh well Ethan
what about Jerry Seinfeld I was like I
don't [__] I don't ride for Jerry
Seinfeld
because he dated
I ride for Michael well I don't know you
won't say anything bad about him
you see
am I saying anything good I don't know
nothing about nobody
these are very nuclear topics for all of
us right yeah that's interesting
immediately yeah yeah but people say
Jersey but Seinfeld it's like I don't
care yeah it's gross yeah either the 17
year old I will say though he's been in
a happy healthy family look his wife is
like a normal age she's not like a young
look I don't care it was gross and
creepy you know I still watch time I
still I was listening I still listen to
Man in the Mirror
I can't help it that's good music I
don't care that he or I mean I do care
that he [__] a bunch of kids but like
what can I do I can't change the past
the music's the music
right Dan
what
Thriller fear of grown man's I like
young penises better than old penises
Thriller
fear of puberty that changes my perfect
voice
thoughts maybe all right
regardless of what I think I'm not going
to say here I'm not going to give you
the satisfaction how about that that's
fair ask me somewhere else guys
absolutely that's fair that's fair
that's fair
and then Sam's is Japan and uh Panic
which is so it's pretty interesting
though
where is love what was love loves his
cheese it's kind of weak yeah you know I
like watches what else could it be then
um it should be Yana
Jenna
you missed it but there was there was an
updated one that AB just found on the
subreddit and they did add I don't know
what Jenna is
assembly oh Jenna died
the side of Jenna
wait why do you oh that's Jenna yeah
because I do I do the decent like I'm
the Deez Nuts guys right right hey guys
I do anything online yeah everyone is
like trying to get me with all these
kinds
try to get me to say slurs and all that
stuff and one slip through genocide I
had not heard that one I thought that
was poisonous forever yeah it was clever
it was good that's a good one I see in
this updated one love that there is a
McDonald's uh apple pie
oh yeah about that
can we talk about it or no I I ate a
apple pie on like a live stream at some
point it was a fly in it
thanks for everything with the flying it
has to be that yeah that's [__] gross
nasty yeah Bob
well and
I fear theorize that I already ate a
couple flies in it why would there be
like a grip of them well I just had a
feeling like the vibe was off I was I
was I said something about that it's not
tasting that good and then I looked
there it's like a fly on there it's just
kind of ruined the Vibes uh here's a
little bit I don't know what the [__]
this is someone made this on the
subreddit named
okay
[Music]
oh my God
that was good nice
shout out by the way to True Crime
YouTubers Kendall Ray and uh Janelle who
are jumping on the Crowder uh Meme and
this is important that we spread this
far and wide so I honor them yeah it is
what does it work for me either either
it doesn't work either
no that doesn't work either it doesn't
work either
how many of the listeners when you guys
were listening to this episode felt like
you needed to do it immediately in the
car I found myself doing it because it's
so nice to save it's like you came with
her either
oh yeah I wanted to say I forgot to
introduce at the top of the show but uh
a friend from YouTube is here Mick
and her significant other
[Applause]
you want to hit it either for us oh you
know what yes I actually did practice
this in my car the other day when you
guys were all doing it so Kayla I feel
you um no that doesn't work either
nice thank you nice
and what's your boyfriend's name I
forgot sorry this is Jeremy Jeremy you
want to hit that or not uh not not
really that doesn't work either I do it
either it doesn't work does that not
work for you either it doesn't work for
him either okay yeah how you guys doing
uh uh Mick is a fan thank you by the way
yeah yeah and um
I'm happy that you stopped by to say hi
yeah thanks for having us we really
appreciate it and you work on like
shorts right YouTube shorts yes yeah
yeah I work on shorts specifically
um usually with like creators who are
big off of YouTube but kind of want to
figure out YouTube It's usually like
tick tockers or Instagram creators
um and they tend to want to do shorts
first so that's sort of how that worked
out there it is Illuminati
[Applause]
did you know what Wachowski before she
retired did you ever meet her I'm
a creator that I
that I work at our office
um in the Bay Area and she's my she's a
good good good good friend of mine
they're real tight super tight I heard
there are pictures of her at your
wedding she's been at like every major
life event that you've ever had right
yeah we're tight
the whole wojinski family is like tight
tight tight yeah but now that she's gone
I gotta make new connections right who's
taking over her position do we know it
was the head of
I know who he is I don't remember his
name he was the head of product or who
is he his name's Neil uh Neil Mohan yeah
he's head of product yeah he has been
there forever
I think he was our old friend's boss
okay yeah when my friend Neil bent over
this happened has he bent over have we
seen his prolapse is that on in public
yet or no
you know I don't think so but I was
telling Jeremy before we came here that
I was really afraid you were going to
make us watch the prolapse would you
like to I mean you're here I I mean I
feel like it's such a deep part of the
lore and I still have not I was I was
just literally gonna ask you
do you watch this show or is it uh
mostly
um Mick
she introduced me to it and now I watch
it more okay okay and have you ever seen
a prolapse uh human prolapse before
um
no all right
because this isn't like a light prolapse
this is like the real deal okay yeah so
this is okay so can we show them there I
know the difference they hold up for
them and then just get their reaction
yeah someone sent it to me I could show
it to him yes so what you're about to
see just to cue this up for you it's a
bit of a rite of passage uh it's a
friend of the show Hunger f f the FF
stands for fist [__]
of course of course and he is the
Premier uh Top Male uh performer
performer who specializes in prolapsing
in fact some have even estimated that he
can prolapse like a full 10 inches out
from his anus
and it's not just along Jeremy it's
thick
foreign
you know what I'm saying good for him
yeah that's great yeah no he's a he's a
real talent and Mick as a fan you've
probably wondered what what was in this
video 100
100 totally if you wondered it can't be
that bad or were you like I'm sure it's
that bad probably some combination of
the two somewhere in between
um but I do anticipate that it will
indeed be that bad it's stunning it is
stunning I mean it really it in my
opinion it really takes
takes your breath away love that so so
the video itself does not go on stream
no
no I'm pretty sure I would be like
immediately permanently banned if I
showed that alive no one from YouTube
will see it you're good yeah
so um
are we ready
oh you're gonna show them on the phone
okay just look real close now look real
close
all right so go ahead and show them so
here you guys go yeah enjoy this and you
put it sideways so I can't
wait how come you can't do it sideways
oh my God
oh
this is Mick and Jeremy I don't think
this is what I expected oh I don't know
do you see them going prolapse to
prolapse yet or no not yet not yet but
I'm sure we will spoiler alert yeah
sorry for the spiders
tell me when you see the prolapse of
prolapse yeah
oh wow oh wow oh yeah there it is there
it is and I've never seen anything like
that neither have I yeah neither have I
the bubbles always really surprised the
bubbles right
I don't know
oh the bubbles no it's very invisible
too oh that was beautiful good job wow
[Music]
baptized by fire oh yeah you know um you
guys did it looking back at my bar
mitzvah photos I I remember fondly Susan
my Torah portion that's so nice she was
my cancer right we sang together with
love and joy in our hearts it really did
not age
[Music]
yeah
for sure she tried to get some
adrenochrome for me I was like I don't
think so
so what do you guys think
that was
[Music]
[Applause]
videos that I've seen
that was uh that was one of them yep
there was yeah you guys will be excited
to know I don't think I'm stealing any
Thunder by saying it I mean I'm hyping
him up Hunger is uh actually made a mold
of his prolapse they just made some kind
of Fleshlight of his uh fully prolapsed
anus that's coming out soon uh Mick if
you guys if you guys want one we also uh
were setting up a call with him too yeah
he's calling in to unveil because I got
one first us and one for Howie thank God
I got one for Ally of course they did he
I just gotta say real quick about Hunger
he is such a good guy yeah and he's so
appreciative yeah he is the man he's
like you guys this audience is like way
better because he was on he was on Stern
he's like you guys are way [__]
better than that [__] like he's so nice
he's such a good guy
he is genuinely a total sweetheart and
you can tell he's very professional
about about it like it's serious yeah
yeah yeah I mean he's like you know in a
sense like Tiger Woods uh he's a he's a
master of his craft of the sport of
prolapsing he's out there on the Green
he's putting in the hours he's the
Beethoven of butthole man nice
so true so true
I have a question for Mick
when you watch the show as as somebody
on the side of YouTube but also a
listener what does it feel like are you
sometimes at the edge of your seat when
some when Ethan is like I have a joke
that I'm not sure if I should say you
know I think since I'm I'm not like your
YouTube rep directly I get to enjoy it
um more so than anything else
um but I am friends with your YouTube
bro and you know he enjoys it too he's a
good guy yeah I think it the decision
doesn't come down from him I know he's
just he's the messenger yeah when he
calls me I get I told him it didn't get
so nervous when he gets well I told him
I said before you call me you need to
message me you're not in trouble yeah
and he started doing that okay that's
good because every time he calls I legit
I'm like [__]
so he started yeah so we have we have a
good uh Rapport in that way yeah yeah
he's a good guy uh so thank you guys
welcome
thanks for having us should we get are
you guys hungry you hungry
after that prolapse video that is wet
your appetite
appetite's abound are you hungry all
right I'm okay okay well I guess we are
not hungry but thank you okay the status
is okay not hungry from that's not how I
interpret them the
kind of looked to me like sure
yeah I already ate so Mick or I mean
Jeremy
you're a little hungry you could have
made it I think he is yeah don't be shy
what are we offering okay all right
don't push
you guys hungry should we get something
for Friday
because we are guests here and stuff
Mexican food I think that would be nice
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah sure we can have Mexican food I
think I'll die if I eat it but [__] it
I'll go out doing what I love I had a
few bites of Ila's burrito and I almost
died like genuinely but [__] it let's do
it
hi
hit me with it Dan come on don't be shy
I just did it oh but I need it dude that
doesn't work for me either
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do you know to do that I can't do
that
oh I don't know I'm from SoCal don't we
all know how to do it
kind of yeah you grow up here if
anything I should know how to do it I
feel like people like
um people in Israel do that
David they'll break so good at it Middle
Eastern one's a little yeah Middle
Eastern
can you do it
it doesn't work for me either
[Music]
I can do it
can we can we can we get one
I've actually done it I've just okay my
aunts and stuff at weddings
uh we could get uh Mexican or to be fair
and I'll go with the masses but that
sandwich place you guys were rocking
with did sound but smell bussing oh that
was really which one I don't know I just
came in one day and they're all eating
sandwiches smelled all good
freaking heck of good dude
but now he's getting Mexican on Cinco de
Mayo that's racist you kept that the
music raises he's doing that getting
what about Italian subs on Cinco de Mayo
true okay fine get the [__] match
dude
but we should get those sandwiches next
week they're really good all right so so
who wants to take the order we'll do
that I know what I want I am I just want
rice and beans
okay
yeah I can take care of the order
there it is there it is hey we got some
Ali London updates holy [__] London
[Applause]
[Music]
I saw the you were telling Hassan that I
was shocked when you showed me yeah and
yeah I want to emphasize like when I saw
that the shirts that he's selling had
kids sizes on it it was just kids just
kids sizes I was like what well just the
iron first of all the iron is exactly
what he's saying he's got a problem with
that he's doing it even more he causing
them groomers it's like and then I do
wonder why does he have kid audience too
he doesn't who why would he make that
that's a good question rumor it's still
on his website
you know well deleting it now would be
admitting that there was something wrong
with it so now he's stuck
three to four years I was like this
when I saw it I was just shocked yeah me
too when I found it I was like oh this
is this is great I'm wait to get his
thoughts on this oh wait what you doing
always Jimmy no fix it yeah so Ollie is
uh still doing a damage control actually
his post yesterday on Twitter was quite
intriguing
um
and and ironic too I'll read it to you
first he says all right after the
extremely rude and unpre professional
interview I had earlier with podcaster
H3 podcast sure where they try to twist
my words they literally said afterwards
host that's me
My Hope in this was that we could at
least damage his reputation producer Dan
it depends how it's selectively edited
ha ha ha
now the degree the degree to which these
guys actually went to prove your
original statement right surprised even
us right yeah Dan's original statement
of course and maybe you can find the
time I remember that this is not how the
conversation went I said I want to
damage reputation and Dan said it
depends how they selectively edit yes
they
they yes of course it was very clear
what he meant yeah and so then watch how
he watch how watch what he posted
I hope that my hope in this was that we
can at least
damage his reputation maybe oh geez nice
cut very uh very elegant
yeah reputation maybe it just depends on
how it's uh selectively edited you know
right yeah we don't need to edit it to
damage your reputation bro well the
irony of selectively editing yeah
talking about how he's going to
selectively edit yeah it's kind of
awesome it's stunning it is it's
stunning and actually
um
because I remember listening to this and
that's not what I got from that
conversation
obviously you guys don't edit the
episode it's a live episode
watch right now with no edits I don't
know what it is obviously so crazy here
is uh the actual statement okay clout I
hope that my hope in this was that we
can at least
damage his reputation with his new
friends
I I kind of feel like it might go the
other way you might have just
alley-ooped him a little bit with his
friends I feel like
I understand what you're saying but at
the same time he has the same points
that he repeats Time After Time
well look it's happening yeah maybe
the alley-oop
alley oops like Kobe
it's happening off the easy I don't know
it just depends on how it's uh
selectively edited you know right
isn't that [__] awesome yeah
yeah pretty stunning
so good well done yeah
okay
[Applause]
Jimmy Jimmy
bed
sausage fingers Chad is saying only
looped
you're right though we should go by oily
London oily because he's a slimy little
[__] oily London a greasy little [__]
you know why he was so annoying how he
kept saying like just offer them mental
health therapy and it's like they
already get that like when somebody gets
to the point of actually transitioning
it's already after years of going
through [__] and going to therapists and
dealing with this well the gender
affirming care is the mental health and
that is
the association for Pediatrics and
Psychiatry these are two different
medical associations that both agree
that children with dysphoria
the the correct treatment is gender
affirming care that's like the medical
literature and medical consensus yeah
yeah uh this is a nice it says us all
waiting for Ethan come back after he
hits the button
oh look at all the details they added
Dan I was having a like Gabe stare off
with him and then you thought it was
frozen right and you were like is it
frozen because I was gonna keep turning
them down but
well because it it had Frozen before if
you recall it's Wi-Fi cut out so I just
thought it cut out again but no it was
just just a staring confidence
that was a crazy one
you know let's see what other stories
Thank You For Fighting the good fight
thank you
for you you know what it's called when
we need it Ollie has a spank it's called
olive oil
a bad [__] with no ass
got him got him wow
yeah yeah
Zach yeah
just trying it on first time
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh we've got a few other stories we got
dubrick on Kik dubrick we've got uh okay
Mom influencer convicted of lying about
kids attempted kidnapping at Michaels
we've got the homeless man saves baby
headed in I saw that video that video is
stunning maybe we should end on that one
it's a real fast one
I mean it's not even really heartwarming
it's kind of like it's more it's just
all bad I don't know oh it's all bad
yeah it's all bad I don't know what I
thought it was a beautiful one I'm
staring at this woman who's just she's
ready to watch her child right get run
over by guess what that's gonna be guess
what that's not what happens not what
happens the child and therefore it is
you read the title of the story did you
guys cut the part where she eats [__]
what's going on here what is happening
okay
they could work at Sears
I don't know how you can tell that from
he's just right he's wearing a whole
black get up he's ducked in them
in the story he had recently moved back
to Liverpool that was actually me okay
we had just left the job interview at
Applebee's can we restart Fredo where
are you going
go get him Shredder can we can we
relaunch this conversation
guys what is this oh wow crazy it's not
the whole thing it is
it shows her it's too zoomed in or
something let it play oh
oh geez
this isn't the whole video
it's too zoomed in
yeah it's like this though I want the
whole shot you know where you can see
her coming out falling in the car and
all this you know what I mean but anyway
here here it is so she oh she didn't
lock the wheels you know how that is and
uh she's but she did try it she comes
out she eats [__] hard yeah
and she looks like older so that could
be a bad but I mean she can't get up and
yeah she's watching and uh well there
goes the baby's literally going like
there's no other out club that baby's
gonna die
it's fine maybe
you can barely see anything
what are you eating dog Alfredo found
something to chew on
uh yeah here it is thank you
looks like that guy from Better Call
Saul you know how here it is here it is
here it is
yeah okay
man
yeah that's so [__] up
oh my God but like I can't watch I mean
this is hell this is hell you're you're
you're just stuck there what this is a
night this is actually a scene from a
night watching your baby
roll into oncoming traffic and and also
the baby's facing her right look at you
can see the baby's face this is gonna
haunt me yeah I told you it's horrible
it's not heartwarming well it's a
nightmare well it's the worst thing
I know but like it doesn't doesn't
matter the Jiffy Lube guy saved her
I mean it does but the scenario is the
nightmarish thing yeah like you say
perfect time at the right place at the
right time dude that is so scary I mean
he's just so terrifying
where'd that guy even come from I mean
damn
holy [__]
yeah
she hit hard too boy she like bounced
almost
she almost did like a
she like body surfed the ground almost
this is terrifying
great
another thing to keep me up at night
the fall is pretty funny though if you
isolate it from literally everything
because you know what it's funny my
nightmare now is like this could be like
a grandparent you know and they like
forget to lock it
the great aunt of the mix oh I wouldn't
give my kid in no great aunt that's far
that's way too far removed
hell no well you don't know the family
situation no great aunt
moving on to the next video of today
but the fall is funny right back no no
nobody's backed me up like I completely
back you up it's [__] hysterical this
cartoon-ass Looney Tunes
thank you over and over again thank you
no I don't want to speak up because
everybody was taken so seriously but my
God this [__] had me in tears this is so
[__] funny well but I don't know if
it's because I'm a parent but like the
scenario of you put yourself in the
scenario it's the worst thing watching
someone fall and hurt themselves it's
very funny so I'm quite confused you
know she hits the ground like a goddamn
bag of dirt
look at that boom
[Music]
she almost was like I'm not getting up
from this
she's like just bury me here
we ever hit this you've seen him when he
hit the ground that hard or both their
legs are up
like a little torpedo stop it
look at that look at that
last time I saw somebody
we have the edit I just dropped it yeah
I was afraid to drop it because you guys
were taking it so seriously yeah Dan and
I worked out this before yeah we have a
little we have a little edit in the yeah
okay
laughs
though
[Laughter]
oh [__] me I hate this ain't no great
aunt watching my baby hell no there's
somebody in the chat said they're great
and raised them okay good for you
there's exceptions to all the rules
right of course just saying in general
but majority no greater great ants
cannot be adjusted
that's a consensus
um
oh my God
this is a fear I didn't need to have I
didn't need to have this in my brain now
I have a new one to worry about every
time I mean the idea of this being on
like what's funny some videos or
something
dude I would celebrate the drums
I thought you guys would kill me if I
drove that no I'm afraid don't get it
Alfredo what are you doing
like bigger than his head and he's
walking with it who's Tupperware is that
he stole that out of my bag yeah
he might have been stealing food out of
your bag because he's been out no
there's no food stinker stinker
did everyone tell you know what they
want I did what is the options uh
Sanders burrito
is this the super spicy [__] up place
where are we ordering from all I know is
you guys this is where you guys usually
get from oh it is the Mexican place yeah
great let's order from the [__] up
Place what's just the thing that's least
likely to kill to make me die of
surprise
salad or something die of dysentery
organ Trail style
um just rice and beans go start a salad
just don't do your normal thing chicken
burrito with extra spicy yeah exactly
don't do that you'll take that
good for weight loss don't get extra
spicy I'm with that Louis Armstrong
weight loss regimen baby yeah no spicy
that's a yes okay thank you Jesus you
know it'll be like you never ate it
whenever you can eat Mexican food he has
to ask for like all the sauces they have
times five and he dumps it all in one
dish like just like a salsa dude
yes it's a soup [__] love salsa
dude's like what's wrong with my Dominic
to be honest with you guys I
have been dieting so hard that I feel
unwell
and I know some of y'all are going to
feel bad for me and be like oh I don't I
don't want to hear it
I don't want anybody to tell me anything
I just want to tell you guys that I'm
dying
I'm not getting enough calories I'm not
sleeping oh my God I'm like
tired all the time
I have super bad acid reflux because I'm
not eating enough so the acid's coming
up into my throat
and I've got like of getting like acid
reflux which I haven't in a long time
so to up my dose of omeprazole
but I'm at I'm at 215 and that's what
the [__] is up
so all y'all who want to say no Ethan
you're not supposed to starve yourself
no Ethan you're not supposed to
go into a medical coma
cheers
[Music]
at least someone understands me
I did it all for the anoki oh there's
Supply there's key Morse so this is what
I'm dealing with but I'm telling you
guys I'm I'm making the progress that
I've wanted for years so like okay we're
going what's happening
it sucks look losing weight sucks it's
like the hardest thing in the world
and it's [__] miserable
but we're dead we're getting there right
but does that mean healthy
when did I ever mention Health it's all
about skinny skinny
it's all about skinny well hell I mean
listen I just want to get there and then
I'll worry about health you know what I
mean
I feel like not enough energy I do feel
like I do feel like you've made so many
good changes that once you get to a spot
that you feel comfortable with then
you're gonna be able to maintain it in a
healthy way because I've seen you do it
recently I've seen you be able to
maintain I lost like the first 20. yeah
I maintained for a long time and you
were eating whatever you want like in
moderation yeah
it didn't it seems very healthy but it
wasn't working for me either
as long as you end up healthy at the end
of your road beautiful yeah once I get
there then
I sit there at the end of the night
while laid out on the couch and I go I
should do the treadmill but I feel like
[Music]
keep thinking about that again maybe try
doing anything about the morning
remember you did it a few times the
morning yeah because also
um we just got so tired by the time the
kids go to sleep it's true I I lately
just crash like I plan on doing things
usually I used to be able to do emails
after they go to sleep and then maybe
draw and stuff and lately it's just like
I get to do nothing I just fall asleep
on the couch I used to well yeah when I
did my big weight loss push the last one
I was exercising at night but I know I
know what you mean
it's just it gets harder to do stuff at
night by the time they're both sleeping
it's like
so exhausting
you never want to dance again
I Don't Wanna Dance Again
[Music]
today
keep it going keep it going
[Music]
dumbass
[Applause]
[__] idiot oh [__] I love that [__]
[Music]
there it is
the lesson from this video
don't trust the great Advance right okay
period on garsh
no but the real lesson always lock the
freaking stroller God damn
true
so that's uh I don't know again it says
homeless so why are we insulting this
guy who's just he came from Jiffy Lube
there's like backstories no yeah there's
backstory to it
okay this man's name is Ronald nessman
he's a former truck driver who
tragically lost his girlfriend
causing him to spiral into homelessness
Jesus
are we does a feel-good story are we
trying to you know what I mean
it's a lie because he's not homeless he
works a Jiffy Lube he looked he looked
ready from what I saw he looked ready to
change the oil
he had just recently moved back to
Hesperia Hesperia to reconnect with his
family oh we got of an interview with
the guy okay now we could really make a
distinction which was uh
going towards traffic and um
what what
I would say it looks like he's worse at
you if you lose
that's homeless done
on Hard Times boy sorry dumb saving
babies learn from the best baby
he's a good man though the second person
runs in to help the woman Good Samaritan
Ron nessman walks the stroller he's a
sweet guy he went and hugged during
stuff she was crying she was just shock
that's why I gave her a hug It All
Happened yeah you're good man afternoon
around 3 30 in front of a1 car wash on
Bear Valley Road we're in front of Jiffy
Lube have an A1 day
that's some good service right there he
was just at the top of that the driveway
right there Ron says he was there with
his sister Donna and was dressed nicely
for a job interview he had earlier okay
looking Sharp
[Applause]
let me go change and she goes no one's
gonna see you but thousands haven't seen
one The Heart stopping they better hire
him hey Applebee's you better [__]
around the world not just an apple piece
job you guys watch the world it's gonna
be a celeb waiter Security Office
security
just invite every
do they Wanna Dance With Me
oh you wanna dance with me it's very
sweet he says the baby was smiling at
him as he oh he brought it back that's
but that's also part of what's haunting
about it yes oh
maybe maybe sad
uh let's see Ezra Miller
[Music]
cooked pasta mystery
this is a strange one we have a cooked
pasta mystery it's very weird hundreds
of pounds of cooked pasta mysteriously
dumped in New Jersey woods
New Jersey's town was discovered a
mystery
in a creek bed
lots of pasta
haunting
so we have all kinds of different pastas
we have long noodle pasta we have
spaghatin yeah
I love it is
[Music]
we've got just what the [__] dude that's
creepy why would anybody do that just
pounds of cooked
pasta
transported out here
left mysteriously by by a creek
problems in the house
I'll tell you man I went down there one
day with my buddy Jim Bob with all the
spaghetti we've been cooking up
left that down by the creek because I
knew
I knew that spaghetti down there
um
it wasn't the only thing about to have
its own Last Supper
in fact me and Jim Bob used to sit
around there eat some of that
spaghetti noodles by the creek and I
looked over at my good friend Jim Bob
[Music]
and I said boy those noodles
last thing gonna slide down that throat
of yours
except for the knife of course
[Music]
got desires too Jim Bob
hate to think about it cause family real
good Christian type they come around
looking for him
I cortome I ain't ever seen in my bed I
just saw him down the last time I was
almost down at the pasta piles I told
them
does anybody in town know about the
Imposter piles we don't know how they
got there but they're there
good old folk from the town they come
eat the noodles you ain't got no dinner
you come down the creek eat some of them
noodles I saw a button
for myself
excuse me you can't find me
it turned your mic off
um
picks ourselves up some noodles down by
the creek it's a good time you know
those noodles like that
nobody knows who make them
but I tell you I've been eating them for
years
so of course Jim Bob's family come
around they say y'all see Jim Bob I say
no last time I seen him was with the
noodles
of course the truth
[Music]
got the gym we got the the John Deere
out there and
start a day
[Music]
this time though to be extra sure I put
a little layer of concrete about foot
foot eight make sure that body was not
tight throw that up
ain't got to worry about
nobody's a good man he deserved to be
floating around like that
[Music]
time I was on that Riverboat down in
Mississippi
[Music]
Steamboat you know the old type churned
the water through the gears and all that
good time out there nice
nice breeze on a hot day that oh rear
boat
but I hate to say it but
as good as it is
good as the memories is that Riverboat
there's some bad ones too and I hate to
think about it but it is the truth
and if there's anything to say about me
it is that I'll tell you the truth boy
ain't no way about it yep
me and jezeiah me and jeze what
yeah we used to hit that Riverboat hit
down that fly fishing on there catch
some of them catfish y'all heard about
in the South yeah they fry up good bar
yeah so me and jezei out there throwing
throwing the line catch bringing in the
the cats as they say
this one wouldn't know what this one
went accident boy I didn't mean to hurt
no just side he's a good man
he's drinking a little bit just aside
drinking a little drunk I said yes sorry
brother you gotta slow down man he got a
drinking problem you know he comes out
he come home he drunk he drive drunk I
try to talk to Jesus I said bro you
gotta slow down
how much he had a hard life he wasn't
ready to slow down none
kept drinking
oh my God I got a friend a b one day
smell of the singed flesh got me
thinking about dark thoughts I ain't had
a long time
you ever tasted human flesh
I tell you man most people won't expect
but that ain't that is not that is a fry
up real nice
you ever cut a steak out of a thigh
clean it up
spread that up
but
[Music]
I tell you man
yeah yeah yeah I'll tell you what man
the thigh tastes good but ain't nothing
like a rump
[Music]